[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo yo realm what's going on
i got my mind right money right
[Laughter]
listen let's talk let's get a mic check
going right quick
let's talk to the people
sinister what's going on
phillip oh javier mccann what's going on
man what are they going to stand up the
mag in there dutch in there oh i see
people ready
got my mind right money right ready for
whoa
let's go y'all know what this is
[Laughter]
gerald back what's going on deploy
what's up how my levels is donna taco
nick's patrick m atomics what's going on
you know what i mean michael brown thank
you thank you yeah yeah we're trying to
stay dry hurricane henry is out here
luckily so far we you know the lords are
okay but um i appreciate it uk up in the
x coin what's up fat boy horror i see
you aim down scope i like that name
that's the type of mood i'm in ain't
down scope
[Music]
dutch oh i appreciate you brother mix up
midweek mix up i appreciate you brother
much love much love so yeah we got a
pack show you already know
the legendary the legendary tony polanco
will be in the building you know what i
mean so we're gonna get him in here you
know king and the crew addict is here
he's getting his mic together
not feeling too well attic what's going
on man can you hear me i can hear you
now the people can hear you too
so he's hopefully gonna try to power
through solver coming through drew thank
you appreciate you fro
appreciate you so yeah we will get
the usual suspects in here king and we
got some surprises it should be fun
but uh it's gonna be spicy i'm just
gonna tell you all right now i'm gonna
be spicy i didn't even gonna hold you it
is going to be spicy today but that's
what we do that's what we do we talk we
address issues a lot of things going on
in the gaming community and a lot of
great topics so we will see you digital
swords what's up bro and uh we will get
into it so i will be back
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is yoga fire flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on a b.o dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boy you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatically i know
it's random but i am addicted to
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on
[Music]
say that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boil you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on the song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
it i'm embarrassed for you i've always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample
[Music]
i'm very spoiled to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta messed up and turn me to
an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you're just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
[Music]
is
[Music]
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for attic
if i can imagine this cooler give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be meto i know it's
my destiny worked a cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it and nothing
is cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are fulfilled but
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right
and we are live hear ye hear ye welcome
to the iron lords podcast llc and also
live on lords of gaming.net episode
number 222. it's another glorious sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's day i'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got halo
infinite co-op and forge delay
ghost is toshiba director's cut and sky
rims anniversary edition plus 12-minute
impressions to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
i want to introduce the lord who i had
the absolute pleasure of being in the
flesh with sam tober at e3 2018
not only will this lord establish
himself as one of the most respected and
honest voices in game journalism but
whose passion for video games sci-fi and
comic books certify him as our cool vet
within geek culture
introducing the game's media journalists
of pc mag and laptop mag as well as the
host of the throwdown show and bright
live
the lord of heavy metal and real talk
with the most iconic new york ice grill
in the game
live from queens new york new york and
making his debut into the realm of the
lords
my man lord rom you death aka tony
polanco how you doing sir i'm fat yo
that is the best intro i've ever gotten
ever man that was epic like i'm hearing
this i'm like yeah let's go
let's get it
yo like man i like i'm trying to like
contain myself right because i got so
many things like first of all thank you
for having me on you know it was a big
honor and i love all you guys man like
you know i've seen you like we cuz we
kind of came up together you know we
started like now i'm not gonna say we're
at the bottom but you know we kind of
were down there yeah
now minorities you know coming up like
that
you know i'm glad you said that man the
minority thing and you know um sticking
with that that's that's a beautiful
thing and i will address that later yeah
yeah for real you know i'm not going to
get we'll probably get into later but
it's like yes i hate i hate the fact
that a lot of us what do we do a lot of
times i'm being honest right now sniping
at each other and stuff like why are we
trying to drag each other down you
should be kind of
oh bro
yeah you already know and you guys know
too who are your biggest attractors is
that white people yeah yeah
yeah all right so we're trying to get
away from that man it's it's a crab and
a barrel mentality but yeah exactly you
know what we have to do is we have to
shed that there's only one in this yeah
but i'm just saying i feel honored thank
you for having me on i feel at home
right now i'm chilling let's go man
brother bro absolute pleasure real quick
before we move i do want to ask i know
you you have to go to school we're going
to get into that but anything else
you've been playing got a chance to play
yeah i played a little bit of everything
lately on the ascent i played some of
that you know that was pretty i i like
the graphics i like the cyberpunk stuff
going on i just i'm not the biggest like
twin stick twitter
um so that's been a little rough right
there and what else did i play there was
something else um game pass been messing
me up with all these games
right now
oh hades hate i played that
because i did not have the greatest
experience with fraternal keep it real
so i'm like yo i'm done with these like
roguelikes i'm like like hey this is
free let me try it out and i played
about like a good hour of i'm like yeah
i think i'm good no no
i think i'm good you know but i think
what was happening is i i need to
revisit those games because yeah i'm
just being honest i just was thinking
about ghost ashima so much yeah i think
i should manage yeah so i was like i i
think i just had that in the back of my
head so i'm like now that i got out of
my system like all right go back and
revisit those but uh yeah man so that's
why i've been playing oh also i played a
little bit of quake uh you know
yes
yo tell me how you felt when you
actually saw it running how they always
intended it to run
yeah it was great because i remember
playing that back in the day day when it
came out you know on my boy's pc i was
like yo it's cause like
retrospectively it didn't run that well
but at the time when you first started
like yo i've never seen a game that
looks like this polygons the 9-inch
nails music like this yeah there you go
trent reznor going crazy
people people really forget what quake
brought to the table yeah i mean we
talked about it in um
it was it was an event like
you liking it kind of to like the last
of us today it was an event game like
yeah that thing came out i love that
experiment that they went through and um
and how it was like a little side
project that they and it blew up it's
just yeah
no doubt so you already know we got the
four horsemen of gaming those original
lords of the realm here at the round
table hopefully a little time-sensitive
intros we got a lot to talk about but
you know we got my co-host with the
close
what happened
it's like you
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
where's this camera lord addict how you
doing sir i'm doing pretty good uh
good to be here man
no doubt no doubt anything you've been
playing sir i know you got a little
headache and all that going on with just
12 minutes just 12 yeah we're going to
talk about it we like i played a lot
more skyward sword but that's that's the
only two games i've really played this
week no doubt no doubt and we caught of
course we have our most technical gaming
lord the sono gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the lord of clarity
and lord patron of the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how we doing sir what's
good what's good i'm chilling ready for
this ready to have the homie this is
what i'm talking about nyc baby i love
it
that's how we do you can put everything
what's going on what you're playing with
okay so first off uh before i'm gonna
get into these super chats real quick
yes um uh daniel is saying in the chat
that he can barely hear tony i don't
know if anybody else is yeah let us know
let's know let us know
yeah let me attack real quick i checked
it beforehand but it's possible uh see
here we go because my mic likes to drop
for you okay okay okay
let me let me know how that sounds no
doubt appreciate it thank you thank you
guys okay so all right super test real
quick we got put the crest in the chat
for the upgraded lord wandering dutch
upgrade oh that's nice
that's the homie what's up
no doubt then we have cedric h ten
dollar super chat oh it's about to be
spicy
you have no idea it's gonna be a forward
all right cool cool and we got fat boy
horror five pound super chat looking
forward to this wait wait to the smoke
the thing is when i copy and paste it i
can't actually no i can't see what the
actual thing in color is fire okay
looking forward to the fire the king
focus he uses emojis
exactly get him okay get him get him
king
yeah yeah we caught up so for me real
quick yeah i've been playing 12 minutes
we'll talk about that in a little bit i
haven't finished it yet but i have some
thoughts
um and then you're going to be proud of
me god wait what
i finished ghost of
sushi i finished it and tony he's going
to be extra proud because i had a lot to
say about ghosts and shoes yes he did
yes he did i finally finally got through
the main campaign
it's good it's no it's good it's it's
it's epic in the way you expect that
sort of story to be yeah it's good it
has the cheesy moments that you expect
but they were beautifully done the game
is gorgeous i can't say it
i stopped i said let me i'll do icky
next week so i'm gonna okay
um have you have you done the black and
white
i did that a little bit yeah though the
curacao i did that a little bit um yeah
that that black and white boy that that
wow
yeah that's been it sir that's pretty
much it yeah 12 minutes what else did i
play a little more hades obviously um i
haven't touched the ascent yet i need to
get into yeah
so that's pretty much it
uh
stick shooter goodness really good and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka the access gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami
you're gonna stop king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement oh b love it
lord king how we doing sir we're doing
fantastic for all you guys feast your
eyes on that prize
[Music]
dcx is is back but it's no longer called
dcx open mic it's called the legion of
doom okay
on deck uh chris barton uh myself yes uh
rodney the punisher and lord vader
thought gunther son himself yes and um
and also
we added a fifth member oh
my boy junior oh [ __ ] out there junior
that's true collector he's he's he's
amazing dude um we had our first show
uh coming back with a different format
and um
it was it was like it felt like home it
felt like
yeah i had this statue um
excuse me
in the box waiting because i knew he was
coming back and um
i was just like it's gonna debut on that
show fire statue brother it's absolutely
insane uh whatever y'all guys see now
trust me in in the flesh is actually
more creepier
out of my price range
it's ridiculous oh that's ridiculous um
okay so yesterday we had uh pacquiao
versus you dennis oh glass and uh you
know who guys won uh he kind of beat
pacquiao to the punch pacquiao was a
little bit slow a foot pacquiao is a
fighter that can only fight a minute 20
uh per round if you can push him past a
minute 20 um you can definitely get the
best of him as you get older in age
uh you lose a little bit of your stamina
pacquiao is an energetic fighter with
lateral movement if you're fighting a
larger uh fighter which is a champion
he's a bronze medal champion um and he
is the actual wba champion it was i um
ironic that the fight evolved into him
versus pacquiao because that wba belt
was actually pacquiao's belt that they
stripped them for so he earned that that
belt in the ring and i really felt uh
great for cuba cuba stand up manny
pacquiao you are a champion uh no need
to put your head down and don't make any
excuses
yeah you lost and i don't know losing is
hard um
speaking of losing his heart oh
all right let's get into a little bit of
man talk man all right here we go
your boy was asleep
and you know i got texts dms and um
it was a little disheartening
uh
to say the least uh because uh an
individual took
time out of his schedule
to craft the video
put the video up edit the video do all
this stuff uh the video is a 25 minute
long video
and um
anybody knows
uh cutting
pasting doing all this stuff and edit it
it's like 25 minutes that's a lot of
work there's a lot of work there's a lot
of energy that's a lot and um
what uh my wives
told me to do
was watch the video
i watched the video
and um
first first and foremost
our elders in this community is our
treasures yes because our elders are
who we go to to to remember the past
because they were there they literally
facts you know and uh this individual
was an elder he's you know he's uh he's
older than me
he's an elder and
um
i watched the video and i saw a lot of
hurt i heard a lot of hurt
um and i and and it's crazy how you can
misinterpret something that someone says
right and you take it to a place where
when i
said you can't change a simp a simp is
going to sim until they you know realize
that that person is doesn't love them
um
that was in general sir
right
if i wanted to call you out of your name
i would have said your name
right
but i understand when you look at
somebody and you emulate them
because let's not get it twisted
those shades
that's
me you
on that crumb side
is me
but what i expect
from a content creator of color
being that i've never blocked you right
even when you did get out of pocket
before and i had to g-check your old
self
and you were in my dms oh i apologize i
apologize i apologize i apologize you
don't pop
stuff in the street and apologize in the
background right
and i want to jump in don't don't don't
don't jump in yeah
because i know i'm gonna give you your
whole name i got you what what what what
i want to say is
i always want you to remember something
you would never ever catch me going a
dealer
you would never ever catch me going at
increment right
you would never
ever hear me say anything about ren or
any any any of my youtube brother in
that regard in taking that time out to
do something like that because again
especially
someone of color because
i can talk to you today
i could say uh that's a minute brother
you said something
it don't sit right with me and i would
address it i would address it right
there on air i would have addressed it
you know right there you could have
jumped on um
there's no disrespect brother
um i'mma say you found your lane
and it's disheartening that your lane is
what it is factual but i want you to
know
remember when your back was cold and
your belly was hungry
and you
were asking for help correct
who reads down correct hold you up
correct correct i got to jump in i got a
job sorry
i gotta jump in all right listen y'all
know i don't i'm all about peace y'all
y'all know me you know what i'm saying
cog is about everybody being together
this console war stuff i get it we fans
of different things and i get it the
issue i have and i've seen it in the
past and the only time where i really
take offense is
if i consider you a friend or someone
that you
support and vice versa we support each
other right look we're all going to say
things that you're not going we're not
going to agree with each other right
that's just the nature of gaming like i
say i will say some things today y'all
not gonna look great
that's just the nature of gaming but the
issue i have where i'm from
grown men if king says something of
anybody that i respect say something i
say you know what brother i'm gonna dm
you or i'm gonna call you if i have your
number say you know what that thing that
you said had offended me you know and
let's work this out as men right what i
don't respect is if we have that rapport
the first thing you do is run the
twitter and tweet or make a video
because that shows me we're not really
friends you are trying to be popular
you're trying to appease a crowd and
that's when i step in and i got a
problem so my whole thing is let's be
men this is gaming it's not supposed to
be serious there's supposed to be a
hobby that unifies us this is kind of
crazy that's what i'm saying like this
is a hobby that you disagreeing is cool
just if you have a problem talk to that
person as a mate let me see
my video that i put up i don't need to
add you exactly
um
that said what is that 20 30 grand or
something somehow and the the problem
with that is the the problem with adding
people is that you're screaming for
attention yes and then the individual
again says oh if he wanted if he wanted
to add me
then i could see it because he put out a
video listen let me explain something to
you
i do not go to sleep with you on my
brain
i'm not going to wake up with you on my
brain and no way in hell am i going to
invest that much time in individuals
when i could just you know reach out and
say whatever and if it's something
that's not consequential to anything i
would just blow past it um some but this
is this is not my feelings this is his
feelings yeah love for that right and i
and i felt the hurt
and and i want to say because it's a lot
of kids that are watching us brother
there's a lot of youth that are coming
up and they want to pick a side like
should i go to the crumb side or should
i go to the side that is actually just
going to grow me as a person
it takes a lot
to grow as a person in a space and to
refrain from a lot of things but it also
takes a lot to tell somebody um i
thought we was this way and i didn't
understand what i have correct um so
again i could have came at you
many different ways
but also
a lot of voice of reason was in there if
you look at all those yeah again
like what are you talking don't do that
yeah like don't say anything don't
address them at all and
i i
as a content creator of color
as an individual with so much potential
you saw all that energy you put in that
video
you could have did a little bit
different
and turned it into a unifying yeah and
then i'm attacking another person
instead of a different vision video
and uh brother
i hear your pain
and and i'm gonna tell you because i
know you watch
i know you follow i know you listen
and i know you wait right
and i just want to say yo with a big hug
o.g
elder
respect brother respect
you you you need to show the youth with
your knowledge that you have right you
need to show them more and i expect more
from you and with that that skin color
that you have
do better right
fracture let's move on we ain't going to
kill it too long paris i know i know
fast with it brother you know you know i
got you you know i got you but i mean i
sent it but at the end of the day we got
to keep it light because i don't want to
get too crazy but um that's been that's
been pretty much it um king as far as
what about gaming sorry what about
getting back to the game oh okay so um
reason why we're here
i got addicted to haiti
and i and i always look over and be like
sovereign you did it again yeah i told
you
no no
disrespecting me i know i know you
weren't doubting yeah 420p yeah
so um i actually uh got really my my son
is crazy in the game and i told him
download and check it out uh
i was playing again curse i can't tell
too much more about curse i thought
curse was ridiculous i was ready for um
destiny but um obviously it's next week
and um we're going to get that in uh
but 12 minutes
yeah
i got a chance it's it's different than
i thought it was going to be at first
like the controls of it and the og
another ochi came in
there
getting used to uh grabbing something
and like pulling it down to do something
um i was trying to break the game i was
trying to do stuff that i couldn't do
like i was trying to take my keys and go
to the next apartment
and stuff like that but um i haven't got
i played actually 12 minutes 12 minutes
[Laughter]
in it
from everything that i'm hearing
this this might be a real sleeper hit of
of uh incredible proportions that you
know people was waiting for that these
are the games that we want something out
of the box something that is uh very
different in the way we interact with
our gaming and i think it's this is
going to hit all those high notes i
really don't know down a little paris i
see you in the building i see you mute i
just want to make sure i did what it
respects your invite but maybe you're
working it out we'll see
but uh no no i'm here oh yeah
you know what david was just talking
about so i'm gonna keep it super brief
yes but the point that you make is is a
thousand percent valid because this is
the problem with us and when i say us
i'm talking about people of color yes
we're the absolute worst
at hating on each other over nothing
over absolutely nothing it don't even
matter who you're talking about i'm
pretty sure i know you're talking about
but it doesn't matter right we should be
working together we should be like you
said uplifting people instead of saying
oh
he likes and i'm doing air quotes the
opposition so let me say some crazy
stuff and bring him down it's like you
guys have been killing it thank you
doing what you do
thank you look look look look football
sees about to start so i don't know yeah
but my point is you guys should be
celebrated for doing all this stuff
people should be supporting you the same
as you're going to support them and like
you said there's so much performance art
with this stuff because you know the
thing i get a lot you know people love
to come at me with crazy stuff right so
every now and again i'll say hey dm i'll
follow him say damn me let's talk
privately one-on-one without an audience
and when that happens
oh oh man my bad you know oh i apologize
you know it's always is always
impossible it's like keep that same
energy if you're going to talk to me
privately that you have publicly that
tells me
you're doing this yes just because you
want the attention exactly it's not
about you really mean it you want the
you want the attention
yeah yeah so i'm not okay bro go ahead
no i don't play good
no i agree with you and like i said last
point i would say just that you know
we've been able to resolve so many
situations behind the scenes with just
little mis understandings or things that
was misinterpreted but like you said for
some people they don't want that because
the the initial reaction is to go public
to make a video to do something to tear
someone down and then it's disheartening
because a lot of people to king's point
i'm a little bit more emotional with
this one because
you know we've helped so many and we've
tried to give a voice to so many that we
think are talented and deserve a voice
and in these situations we've given it
and to see that it hurts because it's
like wow you know i tried to help we
tried to help we tried to give you a
platform and let people know about you
and the first
little issue you run and you do that and
that that part was disheartening
completely agree and i'll say this last
thing and i'll let you guys get back to
it because tony is on here ironically
that's enough
yeah this is tony
paris and i talk about this stuff all
the time man you know all the time and
to your point of what you just said
it does hurt me yeah like i'm gonna keep
it 100. if i see white folks doing that
i really don't care but when i see one
of us it hurts harder yeah yeah
yeah preacher it really does i
appreciate i appreciate you
yeah appreciate y'all i'll let you get
back to it have a good show man no doubt
thank you all right brother
yeah get that workout
with gains brother
look we did we said we had to say we
gotta move on a little bit because we
got a big big show but of course we got
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that realness in
a roman iop not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear yo shout
out to my boy maddie plays defining duke
was lit this week go check that up it is
up 3.99 right now you know what i'm
saying so if you're a part of the
picture you ain't got that you can still
get it free you know what i'm saying so
check that out it's pretty good also
last word with ibottas is up he's back
for vacation
what's up brother hell yeah he's a beef
yeah you know so if you want that
destiny talk a lot of stuff going on
with destiny the witch queen next week
or the same day as gamescom check that
out and for me game wise been playing
the scent a little bit like tony
mentioned on with uh kaibatsuvala khan
12 minutes we'll get into ghost
achievement we'll get into it and that's
it so sorry we're going to get a switch
and then we get into this amazing guest
that we've been procrastinating
[Laughter]
we got somebody spent two dollars super
chat dude was out of pocket for that
video
yeah yeah
five dollars super chat well i guess
i'll say it who wants to play halo
infinite co-op campaign together this
holiday season too soon
anyways have a great show guys
and then we have stone king x with the
thirty five dollars in the chat thank
you so much
wow thank you brother what's up panel
and chat keep up the great work thank
you sir much appreciate it no doubt no
doubt so now we got to what the lord's
been playing and all that good stuff
let's focus finally on lord toady his
video game system history the journey
into game journalism and what led him to
creating his own podcast with those
straight shooters on the throw down show
so lord tony let's start from the very
beginning some of the first video game
systems you had and what got you into
gaming oh man all right so this is an
interesting story right because i was
born in the dominican republic
1980 right
now i had
no idea what a video game was until i
came to america
in 1987 right so the first game i ever
played and i'm just i'm going to give
you my experience as a seven-year-old
right let's go you know and by the way
let me know if i might yo cause i'm
looking at my mic right now it's like uh
the volume keeps going up and down yeah
it might be you might what you have to
do sometimes is zoom has like this
automatic if you go into the uh settings
have like an automatic adjuster you
might have to do that i believe yeah
zoom tries to get a little controlling
so that may be it but it's all great
everybody's still saying
all right they can hear me all right
actually oh i'm gonna do that because
again i gotta come right for the show
you know
it is like this yeah yeah you saw
already like already here yeah yeah
there you go all right let's see how
this okay guys turn it off good thing
i see that second tech skills on the fly
yeah you know so let's talk about that i
got to come right okay so
and i'm trying to do this through from a
x perspective of a seven-year-old who
has never played a video game right
right i mean i'm chilling with my dad's
friends uh bodega right chilling you
know new york you know how we do and i
see this
big vertical box right with a tv in it
and some colorful buttons i'm like what
is that what are those little characters
doing and my as far as i go that's a
game like
um
you know
and i'm like
what do you mean he's like here he gave
me a couple quarters i go play i'm like
what do you mean play what are you
talking about he's like listen you see
that red slot in there stick the
quarters in you press start you play i'm
like okay so i go to the arcade right
and i don't know what it is because i'm
not one of these i'm not like um like
like uh i don't believe in fate or
nothing like that or whatever but
something came at me that day man i
popped them in there and i instantly
knew what to do right right pop the
quarters in press start i'm like oh this
stick moves the characters this makes
attack oh yes i went in bro the first
game i ever played in my life
golden axe man
let's go
after that sega you're king you already
know bro so
after that i go to my mom and yo keeping
it real man like shout out to my mom
like because i didn't we did not have
money growing up or anything but she
bought me all this stuff bro so i was
like
yeah i was like yo i need i need a
nintendo because that was the hot thing
right there i so got a nintendo
super mario brothers contra
duck hunt all that stuff ninja you know
that the really hard ninja turtles yeah
yeah yeah
yeah after that so that's what started
the ball rolling right you know then
after that super nintendo
sega genesis you know shout out to
biggie right there
and then after that i got so into sega i
got the i got the cd the sega cd 32x
sega saturn
that was the first console i ever bought
my own money
is that day one or what is it that's
that's just a little bit into the life
cycle of this of the um the dreamcast
what what's up taking it back all right
again
and i'll i'll admit this i was a
teenager i was stupid i was a sega fan
boy it's okay
i was like screw nintendo
playstation ironically enough like no no
no it's all about sega bro
so
for a year i'm not lying for a year
after the sega saturn got discontinued i
was just like i'm just gonna just play
expert for street fighter imported
version there you go there you go you
had that ram car
did you get your export because you're
from new york where did you get your
input i got it um oh my god and forget
the name of this place it was this place
on northern boulevard okay and um
and like 154th street around okay okay
okay so we're going on a different flap
yeah cps games
i'm enforcing yeah
yeah yeah so anyway so
to answer your question so as soon as
the pre-orders came out for the
dreamcast bro i already started plunking
down my money going in going in like
everybody
yeah so exactly so on day one right i
already had pre-order sonic adventure
right because it's a big sonic
so i go to the store
and i'm like okay i got this and and i
was like i need a fighting because i was
a big huge fighting game fan back in the
day right so i was like i need a
fighting game i see soul calibur i i've
seen soul blade back in the day right
all right like that's cool this is
interesting i guess i'll pick it up bro
that game changed my life
let me stop you right there you're
preaching to me as well like i remember
soul blade it was all it was okay right
yeah but soul calibur i'll never forget
when you see him with the guy with the
staff killik and nakadas and he's doing
the thing and then you see maxie with
the numb chucks everyone had they had
like a demonstration demo mode when you
watch the characters down the most
beautiful
cog
was probably supposed to be doing
homework oh i know what you're talking
about yeah okay
he on the interwebs i don't know where
he found his videos of the dreamcast
multiple videos
oh of the katas right and that's uh
that's just like a demo of the game as
the characters showing the fluidity and
the movie yeah the character right and
the motion capture of the character
we would go in the room she was she it
was her computer she was just like a zen
buddhist
because
we in her room and you know and this is
our computer we're sitting on the edge
of the bed because we don't want it on
the back because you know gotta respect
mama baby
so we we sit on the edge of the bed and
he downloading this little file and the
little file pop up like this this big
windows media player
and you watch it like three seconds of
it and then buffer
oh my gosh
so yeah dreamcast we went crazy without
all those games remember the demo this i
think came with bro
went nuts
i i i subscribed to the official place
yeah the dreamcast magazine that came
with a bunch of them with this yes when
ham yo and the day they announced that
the dreamcast was being discontinued i
was so heartbroken i literally thought
i've said this before i literally
thought i was done with gaming like if
sega's dead what am i going to do
i guess it's over i was heartbroken bro
and so that summer you know and i don't
know how he got it so cheap i think he
was a gotten off of the back of a truck
or something my man said yo i got
playstation 2 for 150 dollars you want
i'm like oh
that's hard to get bro 150
okay sure i'm like like whatever so i
got it yo and now i'm gonna take it back
a little bit right go because even
though i had to like
like i had the front that i had to play
on playstation but when i saw my man
emilio who's also my co-host on
throwdown when he i came to his crib and
he was playing
metal gear solid i was like
what is going on right now bro this is
insane because remember at that point
gaming like acting was kind of not good
it was like resident evil it was corny
like yeah so i'm you're seeing this game
and the acting is just so good so
authentic
exactly and i know all you guys remember
this man this is what messed me up with
the intro right you're getting this
intro mad cinematic and everything right
i can't almost bet you i don't remember
let's go so yeah so you get out the dock
right this is the first first level
right you get out the dock you're moving
snake around and the credits are still
rolling
oh my god you're like where are you
kidding me right now so i got a
playstation 2. i could easily buy
placing two games first game i bought
first game i bought was metal gear i'm
like let's go bro gotta get it in man
gotta stop you again cause that you you
speaking to me preaching to me the one
what was the one it demoed and for metal
gear and we had this demo king
but he he started snake on a boat
and it was that's the metal gear solid
that was the cool demo yeah
i was like
i've never seen graphics that was the
way that they showed the e3 trailer yes
when they show that's right trailer we
said there's no way in hell
i'm gonna keep it real that's just that
trailer alone yeah killed the dreamcast
yes
when people saw that and they were like
oh this little cast can't do this yeah
bro
remember you can put the bodies or the
guards and stuff from in in in the day
oh man continue
yeah you were shooting the fruit on the
side
you were shooting the glasses out it's
crazy the level of
detail and you shoot specific limbs and
stuff like that
who was crazy but obviously that was one
of my first games
interesting thing about that so i got i
got the system 2001 right around like
august 2001 so i'm playing metal gear
you know like the first time i'm having
fun with it and it was heavy right yo
and then 911 hits right yeah and
suddenly that game didn't feel as like
um as heavy anymore because it was going
to arrive but metal gear solid 2 came
out a few months after 911 and it hit a
lot of themes that were going on in the
real world so that game really resonated
with me helped me kind of get through it
because i'm in new york i'm seeing the
towers burning and everything is it's
crazy but at that game and they had to
cut some content because uh you know
watching bridge everything but yeah so
that game helped me out a lot and yeah i
just kept going that direction um you
know playing my plays too i i still
think playstation 2 is probably my
favorite console of all time the super
nintendo kind of eye because i'm like
objecting that yo these are like the
cream of the crop right there yeah
gta 3 changing perspective
no i never never owned it no never owned
it
so how much back compact stuff did you
play on your ps2
yeah it was it was a fair bit
interesting enough i played more back
compat stuff on my ps3 because i had
that um but because ps4 is a good one
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it didn't last very long if you guys
know that yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah but yeah so i went in with that and
then around like the mid-2000s right uh
my homie emilia because i've been
friends with this cat since we're both
13. you know he was like yo tony man you
play so many games you beat them so fast
why don't you start writing about games
like a blog right and i'm like man
that's that's corny man who's going to
go on a blog and talk about that stuff
you know does it because to me i felt
that it was like because i knew a lot of
kids had live journals like why are you
publicly posting this stuff yeah you
know what i'm saying something like i'm
not going to do that horny but he kept
pestering me for years like do it you
would do it and then in um 2010
around october he's like hey i'm going
to start a gaming blog you want to join
in with my all right maybe it's not
going to be so bad if it's just
yeah yeah so i started it's funny right
before that i was a big fan of dual
shockers right uh because it was run by
dominicans right
yeah you already know you're i got the
middle finger
baby
let's go
yeah so so they were they had a fan for
him and they were doing like hey if you
want to write a review for whatever game
you want write a review for us i'm like
i'll give it a shot why not so i just
finished playing enslaved odyssey to the
west fantastic game right
yeah
man that's what started my love affair
with that with that studio you know so i
wrote that review i'm like hey that was
fun and then we started doing the blog
i'm like oh i kind of like this just
given my opinion on games and i quickly
learned like
to enjoy just crafting the best reviews
possible whatever and i in the beginning
i was trying to be like the egms and you
know gaming formers or of those times
game fan all that stuff right
and i was on there for like a good year
and a half just doing my thing and at
that point i was also a big fan of the
bit bag which was run by torrance davis
right a legend in the industry yeah yeah
yeah yeah 1995 he's been in it for a
while right
and he was closing up shop on the big
bag and he was starting up a new site
called uh stfu and play uh
it means exactly what you think it means
because think about like this is just a
little bit of a side think about this
right we're over here talking about how
people talk so much smack about games
how they put how they talk more smack on
twitter than they do then they actually
play games
yeah this was our creed back in 2012
we're like yo stop talking about all
this nonsense and actually play your
game so i'm like nothing's changed eight
years so anyway so i'm like okay i have
all these blog posts he's starting up a
site let me give this a shot so i i hit
up uh torrance by a dm right um yeah
none of the um email right and he
replies to me he got mad he's like hold
on you've been a fan of mice all this
time you've been right you didn't tell
me i would have had you on the [ __ ]
so we started writing and then i started
writing you know for my first
independence height i see if you can
play 2012 so that's when i really
started june 2012 i started covering e3
from home because the site was still
brand new so we weren't eligible to go
to e3 yeah and after that the floodgates
open i started going to gaming events
getting review codes the following year
i finally checked off e3 as a bucket
list thing i went to my first episode i
got to stop you kid just kidding
that is that is a huge deal brother like
you don't understand like coming from
where you come from and then obviously i
can relate because obviously i started a
site like when you get
media credentials that's nuts for your
site to validate that you can cover an
event as media bro that is the highest
distinction from a journalistic
standpoint and i remember i had that
media badge with pride man
bro like you couldn't tell i had the
illest shave bro you gotta
it was one year
that uh we had got we we get the media
badges and stuff like that well we
didn't cog is the only one that got the
media back
right so cog is the only one that got
the media badge and and we didn't care
know go in go get those big interviews
just that yeah yeah yeah go do your
thing mm-hmm
i'm so
so crazy uh i know people out in cali
yeah all right so um
my boy thanos hits me up and he goes um
he goes yo you what interviews you doing
today i said i didn't get the media uh
badge
he goes yo go to the booth just like
that he said go to the booth go put your
name in
i go to the booth they hand me they just
right off the rip gave him my name she
was like oh here's here's your media
badge
all
right
this is my boy thanos like boom he
snapped his fingers
so i had my media badge and i had lord
monkey learn how much the monkey right
so i said he's my camera man he has to
go everywhere i go and then you finish
that yeah yeah but now i finessed him in
so cog is in the media room at e3
at the main house right so
um we me and monkey sitting inside the
media when car comes in like how you get
in here
and i i show my media badge like
salute to you
that was like i do like i said i
definitely didn't want to understate
what tony was saying because it is
important it is important and that means
again that what you're doing the quality
of your writing the reviews you know
what i mean it is respected and your
platform is accepted so continue brother
i just wanted to give you a role yeah no
i'm glad i i again that's why i wouldn't
be on here too because like we just
having a conversation i see it you know
what i'm saying like even though if it
is officially an interview not now we're
just chilling we're talking right now
yeah what i'm saying but yeah no and
you're right you know because i did kind
of just because again for me it's just
history but you're going to say think
about it i was a kid 1995 15 years old
reading egm going yo what would be like
to go to eat it was the dream
yeah and then i finally go to three
hours but the thing is ironically enough
i had to really like ingest that in my
head after the fact because when i was
at e3 i was so focused on my work that
i'm like i forgot like that you know you
know really enjoy it
you know you know by the way bro
that was such a cultural like shock
going to l.a because i had always you
know i was dominican republic new york
and then i've been in new york i've
never left north carolina new jersey
yeah so
yeah i did not like the trip the first
time around because i'm trying to have
that new york mindset in l.a where
everybody's just chilling and slow or
whatever yeah you know what i'm saying
so it was a big
yeah so um the next year somebody told
me like yo go with the flow bro just go
with the la flow and it worked and it
was great after that but yeah and it's
funny i got to say this you know it's
been about fake people right let's go
one of the comments i got the most on my
first c3 and it says a lot about how
fake people are right the comment i got
the most like yo
you act the same in real life like you
do on twitter i'm like why would i
actually
why would
yeah because again it you know where
we're from we're going to be ourselves
he's going to be invented
there's no persona this this is
literally what it is it's funny you said
that what i want to ask you real quick
is yeah yeah was so was your first e3 as
media or because i know like in my case
i had been to e3 before just to go but i
wasn't immediate and then i saw i'm like
damn
you waiting on the line and you see it
oh wow you seen everybody go fast again
so your first e3 was media yes
and it was crazy and we got accepted
real quick too you know and i'm going to
say this right um because e3's evolved a
lot yeah yeah i got
i wanted to ask you that question all
right because uh being that you were on
the forefront of it earlier on when it
was just media going inside and it was
just that you know you got tons of swag
you got you had so much swag you had to
get another suitcase to go home
you know
and then for when they opened it up to
the public
and you got next to nothing swag you had
to buy your own swag
why are you mad about the swag i hated
that part
you were no longer special
we don't have to give nothing away we
could sell it well i think i think a lot
of it has to do is like they didn't put
a whole lot of emphasis behind like swag
at like
um like the ins uh the the xbox fan fest
and stuff right
like when we first started doing fan
fest like they gave you a long oh yeah
we were dripped we were dripping like
because
it felt like every year
it got like less and less and less yeah
in the past like three years i didn't
get him uh fan fest i don't even know
what it was like there no doubt continue
you know it's it's funny you guys oh
yeah
right uh
going from when it was crazy when when
you were media straight through and
there wasn't any fans and you actually
had the space to breathe to talk to the
developers and stuff like that to which
you were there i know you were there
yeah when they let the fans in
and it turned into great adventures and
you showed that
it was people that were non-gamers that
you know
gamers brought their non-gamer
girlfriend
now i gave a kid and she's standing
there on the line i don't know why we're
here
you don't need to be here
so i mean
how how did it feel going from that
whole it felt like you had the whole
cookie to yourself too that you had to
share it with the [ __ ]
at this point in time because i know i
found it absolutely disgusting yeah i'm
the same way so yeah when i first
started right and this is the part that
really kind of like um saddens me right
when i first started i i'm again i'm
still independent side right i got to
play so many games got to be so many
developers because the whole thing was
just open to me i'm like yo if you try
to do this as independent person like in
2019 which was the last e3 it would have
been impossible with all those friends i
remember i think when they first opened
up 2017 like really opened up i'm like
yo this just turned and i'm saying this
in a bad way and i do love this
convention but in a bad way i'm like
let's just turn it to new york comic con
right now which is just a swarm of
people and they have no coordination
whatsoever thankfully i had you know my
appointments or whatever but even get to
some of those like bro this is crazy
right now but so yeah it was it was very
um jarring as a journalist and i don't
feel they did a correct job of
separating the two like thankfully by
the last year like they had all my
appointments upstairs or whatever so i
was able to do my thing but at the same
time i'm cut off from everything else
you know yeah um so yeah that i i
definitely felt that and i really felt
worse for the independent guys who you
couldn't get work done if you don't get
like appointment stuff you're not
getting any work done because you know
because you have all these other people
and i'm not saying you shouldn't have
the public in e3 i think it's it's good
but it's just have it separate a's
because right but if you're independent
and you're trying to play a game you got
to wait on this long line i'm like bro i
i will say this does it happen to me i'm
not going to name the company right
where i had an actual appointment right
um and i'm playing the demo and they're
like oh you know you got to end the demo
now because we got people behind your
mic yo this is just fans i'm not worried
what are you talking about you know are
you kidding me right now
so yeah so i hopefully you know if it
comes back after you know this whole
rona stuff like hopefully they'll
they'll do it in the vein of tokyo game
show or gamescom where they have the
press days and you get the fan base and
everybody's happy you know yeah
i have a feeling if e3 comes back next
year
it's probably just going to be media i
don't think they're going like i think
they're because of what's going on right
now and i think that a lot of like
especially organization
organizers like
they're
they're really like skeptical of like
asking for vaccines yeah and they try to
stay away from that type of
uh community took a long time before
they made it yeah so i i think
they will feel more comfortable if it
comes back
yeah
that year
because like it's neither of them do
that or because i
you could probably get away with it with
with vaccines if you're just doing media
because they're going to feel like they
you know if they want to go for work
they're just going to have to get it
yeah but when it comes to like the k
like the community yeah that's a
different ballgame the problem is the
financial aspect and yeah it's a lot you
know comic con is going through the same
thing right now because they took
everybody's money and then
they told them after the fact
you have to be vaccinated
after yeah the fact that after the fact
you don't get your money back for your
tickets and stuff like that so it's a
big controversy where it goes to that
but i understand what you're saying no
doubt but yeah tremendous experience
with e3 i love hearing those stories and
yeah e3 was a trip but yeah
i think
my first e3 was the year before they no
my sec my first and second e3 was the
years before
it went public and it was like i felt
like it was getting more crowded even
then like from year to year
like maybe the criteria is to get media
was was lowering
because if it felt pretty well that was
that year before that was when they
already had the the
explosion with with people oh yeah so
you know
he was like just coming just everybody
connected yeah and everybody started
getting because
yo tony yeah um
how did you navigate
the choices because a lot of the shows
are at the same times what we will have
is team a and team b or team c
they will go to excuse me the pc show
yeah while one will go to the ubisoft uh
event while the other one would be
hitting the ea event and a lot of these
events are happening at the same time
and you have to navigate which is your
priority did you go by what was going to
be the hottest game that that at that
time like you know all this madden is
gonna be crazy or they they debuting
live uh you know nba live is out there
and it's it's actually gonna have the
next gen features or was it more about
um
your love for each studio game like the
division is going to be over at ubisoft
and i actually like the division two and
let me get over there how did you split
that up because i'm pretty sure at this
point in time you're still working alone
or did you have a team that you was able
to split up in your team yeah thankfully
i've never gone to e3 by myself i've
always had a team various sizes
obviously but like the first year we
were it was like six of us we went okay
so we were able to split the workload
and all that you know and it was like i
guess when i was i'm writing for a
geek.com i'll get to that in a bit like
we had a smaller team and the site
wasn't like ultra focused on games right
so i was like let me just focus on the
big stuff you know the ubisofts the eas
and microsoft and sony so like the pc
gaming stuff i left that alone you know
we didn't really cover that that's not
really what the audience was looking for
so i always like at e3 just focus on i
try to mix it up too it's like focus on
like um at least for the main shows
obviously focus on big stuff but then at
the actual event
a mix of both you know the big stuff and
the little stuff and a little bit in
between because there are a lot of uh
awesome awesome pr people that i want to
just check out their games and you know
give them support and all that you know
what i'm saying so i try to always uh
split it up as much as possible although
i will admit though 2018 i did way too
much
that's how bad it got i remember it was
the it was the first day of microsoft
had their event in the morning right and
then we had all this other stuff going
on so i'm thinking in my head like all
right bro i'll get because i because we
were running a little bit late i was
like i'll get something to eat after the
microsoft event right
but at the microsoft event afterwards
like you know pr he'll be able to yo
we got a bunch of interviews lined up
for your money okay so i did all that
and then i had all these other
appointments so bro i didn't eat
6 pm
you know shout out by the way shout out
shout out to valerie turpin who's one of
the best pr people out there if not for
her not apple and cookies
i still remember this the first time i
met you was right in front of smash
burger right so that saved my life so
when i got that smash burger afterwards
i bought two of them joints bro oh damn
my god that's like a meal for like three
days people don't understand like you're
on your feet people like you understand
like tony's really nailing it
it's work
like it is work like don't get me wrong
you love the pledge of covering games
and there's all these games there you're
excited you're seeing your people you
see your colleagues all the biggest
names in the industry around you that's
great but you're on your feet from the
west hall to the south hall to this
location to that location then you get
into the yeah getting to the point where
i was like we're doing everything in the
west hall
over there yeah
we're not we're not going into that
middle courtyard with all the trucks
like i'm not leaving
yeah
i am not leaving this room with this
building until we do everything we need
in this building yes
that's how you do it bro you gotta have
comfortable shoes you don't see it like
the sticker game better be right now oh
i learned that the first e3 when i i
rolled up in there with some like some
haraches or something like that
oh my god
uh because one year
so some of the lords like rented cars or
something like that
me and cog they ended up leaving early
because we was like we just gonna uber
there like we ain't doing that so
they're trying to find parking for like
45 minutes so oh man we get shout out to
l.a traffic and he's driving he just
drops us off and we're like yo like
we're like we're under a bridge we're
not even at the convention
he didn't really speak the best of like
english so you don't you can tell he
didn't really know what you're saying
that man made us walk from that place
yes like a quarter of a mile yeah really
yeah yeah he left us wildfire but in his
defense the traffic was so wild that you
got to do that
yeah this is why this is why because
that's always been an issue with la
right the traffic so in my last e3
that's like okay this is what we're
gonna do we're gonna go to hotel because
i'm a new yorker i'm used to taking
trains and all that
i'm i'm gonna get a hotel right by the
closest train station because there's a
there's another station right by the
adventure center right um the
neighborhood was a little bit sketchy
we stayed in one of the areas little
korean town areas a little sketchy it
was it was it was a little creature it's
a sketch
because we know that we was there one
year
they had it but they had a denny's right
down the block so we were chilling right
there and this sketchy ass hell 7-eleven
yeah
it goes down i know which one you touch
that
i know you already know
when the parking lot is gated like that
like because they steal your car like
you go yeah
yeah that was wild bro so but it's funny
about that um right down the block
there's this place i am not kidding the
place was called king of new york pizza
right so we're like all right let's go
check this place out let's see what's
going on and i will say this for la
pizza yeah it was pretty good
it was not bad at all ironically though
the next week when i come back to new
york i went to some random
hole-in-the-wall pizza oh my god
e3 was crazy but let me go back a little
bit um i do want to say this though
because a lot of people don't know this
because it's not really something i
focus on it's not really i think but
it's part of it right i'm in a
wheelchair right the reason i got that
way is because back in dominican
republic in the early like late 70s
early 80s was a big pandemic going on no
i didn't know you was in a wheelchair
exactly three years
yeah so i got polio right you know
because i was going on back then
and um and i don't talk about this too
often i had a twin brother you know he
unfortunately bid it or whatever
um
so
but what i love about gaming is that my
disability has never like impeded me
it's never been a liability you know
what i'm saying so it's funny i was
thinking about that when you guys were
talking about you know the footwork like
i never had to worry about that e3 but
yo my arms
it's an event but it's work it is worth
so much people forget people don't
realize that and that's why i respect
about king too like we're out there he's
out there we got the team split up it's
a movement you know you gotta yeah you
have to get your battle plan ready yes
yeah you have a battle plan going out
there and um my thing is you gotta play
to your strength my thing is talking to
people street team you get out there
you're handing out t-shirts and you're
moving because i don't take anything
personal if you don't take a shirt god
bless somebody will and i pass off the
shirt because everybody is thinking
somebody's trying to sell you something
i'm not trying to tell you something i'm
trying to give you something i want you
to give back by following us and um
and hopefully our content will resonate
with you because we are gamers for the
game it's body games about games right
so we're we're doing that we're pushing
that
out there but while he's out while he's
inside working i'm outside working right
and i and i and we have this belief and
system within each other that we know
that we're doing our best at our job at
that point in time but i don't get to
play games until thursday yeah yeah if
right and then i come in on a friday
which is probably the last day and i
actually get a chance to touch something
that i really care about something that
i really like that's spiderman i touched
that yeah yeah during the week i don't
play any games there's like there's no
gaming for me yeah i have like the one
rule thing it's like
one game i'm a sitting line one game in
one game only like
like usually it's not zelda usually ends
up being damn destiny but like one game
i'm gonna sit in line no it's never
zelda because that likes too long
i remember one was i i i guess it was
ff7 for attic that he was like i'm just
going to stand here no matter how long
it takes i'm going to stand with me an
hour and a half to get there yeah no my
rule is like listen if i don't have an
appointment i am not staying on no lines
no i'm not dealing with that none of
that nonsense for me you know um but
yeah i do want to go back a little bit
here right so obviously i would start
going through going to these events and
what's cool about you know my first
event was the ea event right here in the
city right and that's when i felt like a
real journalist because before i was
just it i was like i'm just a dude at
home writing so when i started going
these events meet my peers and stuff it
was a trip right but when i first
started i started thinking like yo
maybe i could make a career out of this
let me just keep grinding doing my thing
and just keep going right and then late
2015 i got hit up by my man jeffrey
wilson right i've been friends with this
guy forever and he was like yo uh we
need some news content over at pcmag and
geek.com just for just the the winner
right just like a little trial thing and
i'm like and you'll be getting paid for
my word
all right and it was just funny because
i'm like okay so you're asking me to do
the same thing i've been doing for free
just
for a major site so i did that for two
months right and then at the end of it
uh pc mag was like you know thank you
for writing for us we you know we had a
good time if you want to submit some
more stuff to us you know please feel
free to geek.com was like yo you want to
just keep doing what you're doing just
more of it so i'm like oh yeah now i'm a
professional journalist now
so that was a trip to taking it to the
next level and i'm like for the past
five years actually you know it's about
these six things like i've been making a
living off of this it's just so such a
trip you know met so many dope people
throughout the thing so the whole larger
point is like listen if you have i know
it's gonna sound mad corny but if you
have a dream man you gotta pursue it you
gotta work hard like as soon as i i
figured i'm like yo i could do this i
just put my all into it i finally got to
this place you know and obviously i'm i
haven't just stopped i'm still trying to
take it to the next level you know so
you are you are uh that's why we had the
solution man we had to commend you i
believe on p giving people their roses
you know i can smell them don't wait
until you know after and the thing about
it is obviously the grind
your commitment and then turning it into
a career right like turning it into
something that is now tangible something
that was a hobby that you have passion
for for gaming and now into that what i
did want to transition into is also what
i think is really cool what you're doing
as far as like the bright the bright
live stuff and yeah that's really cool
because like giving people a platform
and teaching them like how to get in
given that knowledge like to provide how
to become an online journalist like what
how did your involvement with that start
and like why is that important to you
yeah all right so huge shout out to
danny pena right he like yeah
that's my dude right there right so he
was one of the first people that start
because bright is a relatively new um
like platform and it's basically for you
guys who don't know bright life you have
people who are knowledgeable in specific
fields yes talking to audiences but the
cool thing is unlike you know like a
twitch chat or whatever it's just people
typing stuff you could actually pull
people in right video and talk to them
face to face and give them your
knowledge right so he was like yo tony
you would be great for this with game
journalism and it's true because ever
since i started i'm talking like even
when i was independent i would have
people dm me like yo how did you get
into it what i need to do so now i'm
able to do that on a larger platform and
one of the things i've always believed
is uh paying it forward right i had
people that helped me
get to where i am so i'm like let me do
that for other people you know what i'm
saying like for example when i started
like writing professionally right i i
got so many more pr contacts right you
know what i did to my with some of my
homies i'm like yo you didn't get these
from me you know he's like yeah
that's it
that's what you know bro and i think
yeah and i want to say this right now
i'm so glad i'm here on this platform to
say this right um and i tweeted about
this a while ago right because you know
when they one of the things they tell
you is like if you want to get oh ahead
anywhere you got to make contacts you
got to make connections which is true
but it's always in the context of you
got to make connections to get yourself
ahead while that's true you also want to
make connections to get other people
ahead because if you're not doing that
what's the point of this point
shout out to 108 in the chat here's my
homie right there he said each one teach
one yes absolutely man completely agree
you know we all try to pull each other
up and people don't understand like
instead of this whole crap of the battle
mentality we could win together like the
problem is big enough for everybody
everybody can eat and everybody brings
something different
you know no your take is not gonna be my
the same take that i'm gonna have on
something and you know who you resonate
with may not be the person that i reach
and touch i don't ever try and i don't
ever care to reach millions and millions
of people i just want one person
that one person that that same little
kid or the same dude
who had that same experience and i want
that a real connection that yeah
yeah oh yo i got to say something about
that because it's so important right and
i learned this at my first pax east
right 2014 i was at dual shockers at
this point bigger site right and one of
the comments i got after the fact
because in my head i was like i'm a
gaming journalist just doing my thing
right one of the comments i got the most
like yo i appreciate the fact that i'm
seeing a latino doing his thing in the
game
i have never thought about that right
yeah and then i'm like internalized i'm
like hold up he's right about that
because like for example if i see like a
byline right like adam sessler that's
cool but if i see a bun like brian
crescent i'm like oh hold on whoa whoa
whoa hold on hold on
i thought about that i'm like oh wait
somebody sees polanco i'm like oh okay
so that then that's right
exactly
and this is something that torrence
taught me yo by the way i gotta say i
love the fact that all of my editors
have been black people i love it you
know like because they want they see me
like yo you're making i want to raise
you up you know my man jeffrey uh cherie
taylor torrance like all right yo i love
all of them but um torrance taught me
this like listen man we are not not he
wasn't saying this in a derogatory way
or he's like listen you are probably
never going to reach those like
popularity levels of a greg miller or
carl moriarty and that's okay because
you are reaching a very specific
audience who are neglected speak to them
and i'm like when i when i realized my
yeah you're right it's like if i
reaching out to like a million people
are great but if i could really resonate
with like 100 or 200 people yeah oh good
yeah you know you know what i'm saying
so i try to focus on like yeah i realize
i'm not like those type of journals and
that's okay because they're not me
correct correct they're not me so let me
just do what i do and just keep it going
it's been going very well for me so you
know it may not be for everybody like
you know obviously when you get up there
like that you get a bunch of hate which
i get all the time which is fine
i always say like like um like a video
game like you know you're going the
right path when there's a bunch of
enemies around you yeah
i like that they show up
i think that's hilarious yeah i think i
think that's a beautiful thing but then
also at the same time those are people
that are
upset and it's not really upset at you
it's a reflection within itself because
you taking that you're having that
courage they always want to have that
courage to do what you're doing it takes
a lot listen man it takes a lot of
courage to get on a flight it takes a
lot of courage to to go and believe in
yourself it takes a lot of courage
because
you're going to have more no's then
you're going to have yes's yes but
you're fighting very hard to get that
yes you're fighting very hard to become
accepted in in something that you love
so much and it's that love of that
medium or that love of what you're doing
that's actually driving you
because it's sometimes you look at it
and you say man it's not worth all
though i did i didn't get the views
that's not worth it i can't think like
that man you can't you know because
that'll pull you down you know it's
gonna lessen you so you can't be worried
about that focus on doing your best and
you will reach your audience you guys
have done it you know what i'm saying
yeah i'm mankind all these shows with
colin
like it's crazy man you know i don't
know i love it i love it
yeah i agree but then i disagree because
like
it's one thing to have that mindset it's
thing to break through the mental
barrier to have that mindset like
it's like you know you spend hours on
this you don't reach dollars you want to
because then that now like you know it's
hard not to think maybe it's my content
maybe i ain't doing something right yeah
it's hard to not get frustrated yeah
it's hard to not get down yeah
there was times where iop was almost a
wrap well he was like look you know
maybe we just maybe people ain't ain't
feeling and then what was the
conversation we had we sat there and we
said you know what i love doing this
i still love doing it and at the end of
the day i know we know it's something
special is going on it's just going to
take time and you know to me i always
equate it in solving king knows like
tortoise in the hair you know something
some people are going to jump out you
know yeah but as long as you stay steady
and you're doing you're doing and you
improve you're willing to take criticism
when necessary you know take your ego
out of it there was a lot of things i
had to check on myself i was like yeah
king with the cameras adequate with the
platforms you know what i'm saying
software on the business side all these
things we learn from each other and then
we help improve to get us a bit better
and then it happens but yeah this is
being real yes
it means the most because like you said
you know that little dominican kid that
doesn't know that uh he can do what
you're doing yeah like you you showed
him
and then he's going to dm you and say um
how how yeah yeah that that has happened
you know i got a lot of people that
follow me with that little dominican
flag they know what's up yeah they know
what's up
and you're right about that and i also
got into like yo i didn't know we could
do that i'm like whoa like the fact that
mentality exists means we need to go out
there and crush it because people
shouldn't be like that preacher you know
like you should believe you can do it
all right you know
we already feel that it's already set up
because the way that it's uh produced to
us what we see is not us yeah that's
right yeah we understand
so
that it really means more to me
especially when you see hispanics so you
see
paris out there like that yeah man
i saw him on that stage i was so proud
yeah yeah it came as a other shock to me
yeah right one that you know that he's
doing he comes out there and i think i
thought they were gonna have like a
small part no
it wasn't just a small part
you understand like you had control of
this
this this vehicle you were driving the
bus
and i looked out there and he did such a
wonderful job
and i said thank you
thank you because it's going to be uh
another paris
ladies right that opens the door right
gets people comfortable it's going to do
that because a lot of these
opportunities aren't affordable i i
really respect hip-hop gamer yes i
really love shout outs
because he's probably one of he's the
one of the most giving persons i've ever
met
like from his from his heart like
literally from his heart he's a very
loving person like a loving guy and
he he he's out there he he kicked that
door yeah he goes one of the first yeah
he goes and then he represents us
so
i really respect him and love him for
the stuff that he does because a lot of
times
they knew him before we
showed up that's right and the the
craziest thing that he's ever did i'm
gonna stop real quick um he was doing an
interview
this is this is big because this is when
control is getting ready to drop and
he's having this interview he sees us
walk past he pulls us into his in the
middle
with the devs
right there he didn't have to do that
mm-hmm
but that's that that's not a crap
mentality exactly
it's enough for everybody and i and it's
is an abundance and you have to see it
as an abundance and not a small fraction
that will be stolen away you don't have
to hold the cookie to yourself yeah you
have to split that pie no doubt yeah i i
i got to throw this quick story just to
show you how much of the you know
gerard's character right so 2009 i was
not even blogging or nothing right
i was just a regular fan right 2009 new
york comic-con i see my man walking down
the aisle with his entourage
i'm just nobody at this point i'm like
yo hip-hop he goes yo what's up he comes
up to me he takes off the belt puts it
on me spins it takes a picture with me
he wants to see how i'm doing then we
exchanged numbers and we started talking
before i was even interested so think
about it like he does that with people
who are just regular fans i showed you
his character and till this day he's one
of my biggest supporters i talk to him
all the time behind the scenes i see him
every time we go to events and stuff
like yo that that's my dude right there
you know and that's why you know when
when people try to come at him i'm
always trying to be defending them you
know what i'm saying no no no it's the
same thing
yeah
it's like look you can
you can feel a certain way about a you
know statement someone says but it's
like
you cannot question their passion it's
like yeah like hip-hop like that dude is
the embodiment of passion for the game
facts like it doesn't matter what it is
what it not is and like what's funny is
like he's gotten to the point where it's
just like if he knows people don't like
it he he he he gonna he's gonna
capitalize on it
it's like with the whole cuphead thing
he's like i'm gonna tell you what i'm
playing
he's like brody's cheating
salute man we gotta move on because we
gotta get a lot of stuff going old buddy
tremendous history love the gaming
stories love the journalism story i got
a fun question i gotta ask before we get
into the questions which is um now
lorton are you from my beloved nyc and
we know that is this uh nope it is the
birthplace of hip-hop
hey queens get the money no doubt
however you know one thing i find very
unique about you
is that my van is a fan of heavy metal
huge passions so how did that start and
i need you to educate me who's
on the influences tell me what's going
on in these heavy metal streets yeah by
the way i'm i'm tying everything up
right now with the metal stuff and the
minorities and that's going at all
they're right because one of the
misconceptions is that like you know oh
it's heavy metals just white people
right all my friends in my inner circle
that i know that love heavy metal
they're also minorities too right and
there are no more passionate heavy metal
fans than hispanics and like the bands
will tell you it's like yo when they go
to south america it gets hot because
it's crazy but yeah for me it started
again when i came to america because i
was like you know i was just saying to
regular pop stuff even i still love you
like michael jackson i love all that
stuff or whatever um but yeah it was
when i came to america and i started
seeing and this one because they're not
metal at all they call them metal back
they're not metal all those hair bands
and stuff but i saw bon jovi i was like
because they were bigger like those
videos they look better than life you
know so i i like and i just love the
sound of the guitars i think it's just
because of the kind of person i am i'm
just very aggressive like that yeah
exactly so you know i started getting
into like really hard rock and stuff
like in my early teens and stuff or
whatever but it wasn't until like the
late 90s when somebody because i i liked
metallica right
yeah it was the blackout which is the
the more popular that's how i'll blow
them up right but when somebody let me
hear and justice for all the album they
came out before that when they were real
i was like what am i listening to what
is this like like the music was just so
intricate so heavy that they were
talking about all this heavy stuff about
politics and all that like like yo this
is serious right now let me check the
old stuff so then i started getting into
slayer pantera fear factory like this
heavy heavy stuff like i went in yeah
yeah so yeah so it just resonated with
me you know what it felt like yeah guys
go ahead i'm not investing
i don't know i don't know too many white
people that that do it like i don't like
at all whatsoever like
like none of my family in arizona listen
i haven't been no one around here
listens to it like i've noticed like
white people generate literally neither
go towards like like light rock okay
yeah hip hop or country music there's no
way
i think a lot like i don't
like there are some people
that like it but for the most part like
out of like maybe 100 of the white
people i know maybe one percent of them
listen to him
interesting he had a question tony yeah
um you know
the album covers yeah yeah are you a
collector buddy are you a collector of
these vintage album covers because the
artwork i felt with him yeah crazy crazy
insane
yeah i i would be if i lived in a bigger
apartment i got to watch what i
i got to watch what i get yo and it's
funny you know going back to we're
talking about before with swag i'm that
dude i'm like unless it's a t-shirt i
don't want your schweins i don't want to
carry that back home
bring an extra extra suitcase just for
the smell
i've gone as digital with everything i
could books
games everything because i'm like i got
it
all right good
what's your favorite album cover
for your favorite band and why
for my favorite band and one here's like
i don't have like i do have favorite
bands i don't like i like picking one
because like my feelings will change
like but if i have to really just the
album cover and because
i have i have led zeppelin yeah yeah
album cover
and it's it's
it's really good but i i just i just
want to i just want to know why just
just because i'm i'm a junkie for the
album covers okay so i'm gonna go with
this one because this is one of those
albums there's two of them but i'm gonna
pick one that i feel like if aliens ever
showed up i'm like this is what metal is
about listen to this you know so it's
from 1990 is judas priest painkiller
right and the album cover is this like
metal like this it looks like a robot
dude he's on a bike it's shooting flames
the whole earth behind him is destroyed
scorched and he's just like
this is crazy and if you listen to the
album the album sounds like that like
the whole thing is just like in your
face and intense you know and again it
just fits that energy that i have like
if i want to chill the most laid-back
music i listen to is like ac dc or
something
[Laughter]
he listens
whatever
whatever that is i like that
you got to build strength forward
because like for example when one of my
friends tried to put me off the death
metal first i was like yo i don't know
what's going on this too much but then i
bet but then i went back like listen to
some swedish death which is a little bit
more melodic right and then i graduated
to the heavier stuff so look if i'm
listening by the way i'm putting your
whole audience on to all this stuff
right now so if i'm listening to
something like nile nile which is like
probably the most brutal death metal
band ever like yeah something like um
like like queen sort of swimming or
whatever that was like yeah that's light
and cold
so the seven they should all be enjoying
that
i thought it was hard i thought i was
doing something
you thought that was it like that that's
mind-blowing that you thought i thought
that
like for example like oh you like
slipping i'm like that's a little too
poppy for me man yeah you know what i'm
saying i can assure you something right
now eight
nine nine out of ten at the time
battlefields not having a heavy metal as
they uh as they look
the question we asked in realm to finish
up the interview portion is i need lord
tony's top five video games or
franchises of all time
oh all right i'm just gonna do this i
don't actually know the first real
probably in order then i'll just go
crazy after that
my favorite game of all time till this
day metal gear solid three right
right snake eater and i'm you know i'll
try to keep it brief but there's a
reason for that man best best song ever
yes yeah bad game
right like i remember playing it for the
first time right you know
you're this new guy boss taking place in
the past and i'm a big history guy so
it's all about the cold war i'm like oh
this is crazy right now right so you're
playing through the game and you know
you meet the boss you get messed up you
get thrown down this bridge and stuff
your crack
fades out
then the logo meg that was just the
intro of the game
i lost my mind man you know i went crazy
but then after that you know it's like
there's so many things that i gave you
could do i love how you could mess with
the guards right because they had houses
specifically for their food and their
weapons right so what i would do is i
would go and burn both of them down
right so i would get to a point where
guards would be chasing me with knives
i'll punch them once and they fall over
because they're hungry
and my favorite boss the end
oh um the first time probably about an
hour right right i kept that boss fight
specifically on a memory card because i
had to i wanted to keep me playing
because there's so many things you can
do with them the first time i did i did
it just normally i'm still thinking
around the jungle and stuff trying to
get them right yeah but then i feel like
let me mess with this dude because he
would always send out a parrot right
after me you know to be able to look at
so i found the parrot i would eat them
you know you could do that yeah you get
mad you know sometimes sneak up on him
or my favorite thing you do you could
change the clock on the playstation
and he dies
she's so old he dies
yeah and then your people call you up
like that's a dishonorable way to win
and you could even take him up before
that because he's he's like being
wheeled around a wheelchair you could
snipe him and kill him and like you
don't have to have the fight so yeah
metal gets hard to be my favorite second
one and this is relevant you know
because it came out this year
re-released mass effect 2 man oh wow
effect 2 man yeah so yeah i'll i'll keep
this even briefer but it's like okay
when i played mass effect the first one
right i was like oh my god this is the
star trek game i've always wanted yes
you know like you you felt so immersed
in the world so the second game took
everything i loved in the first one just
took it to the next level
here's how i liking it mass effect 1 is
like a great sci-fi movie mass effect 2
is like a great sci-fi series right
because you have your overarching
narrative right but then between that
you have all these sub stories that just
enrich the universe that game
when i replayed that because i had
already played like five million times
back in the day when it came out but
when i play yo they don't make games
like this anymore man this is on some
other level right now you know all right
so that that's number two number three
and this one like you're noticing a
pattern i like games that make me feel
like i made a movie yes you know let's
go um
uncharted two
yeah we charted two what's on all yo
that game and also changed like the
course of like gaming within that
generation but i love the fact because i
i really liked the first game right but
this one it just took those set pieces
to a whole other level yeah you got to
you got to see nathan drake more of him
and all that but i just love that i was
like i'm playing a real indiana jones
game right now this is absolutely insane
man you know so i love that number four
i gotta take it back a little bit old
school uh because i love again 90s was
all about fighting against me but if i
had to pick one um the culmination of
everything and i wish capcom would
re-release this because i'm like this is
what started everything
x-men versus street fighter
yeah exactly a lot of people i think
because
think about it from my standpoint in the
90s right i love capcom fighting games
yep i love comic books
perfect that's that's when they um lost
the the right to like do
mutants or something like that yeah
infinite bro yeah infinite was uh the
amalgamation of just only the disney
properties uh being there and then they
finally own all of it now so we might
get that we might yeah
i would love that and then game i got i
got to go old school with this i got to
go old school and i'm pretty sure a lot
of you guys here will agree with me on
this one man
turtles in time man
okay in time you already know it's
together yeah bro cause we were all
playing the beater most back at eight
but that one specifically bring apple
three yeah bro
classic man how you feeling about that
that release of i'm ready yeah i'm ready
i'm ready i'm ready yeah cause we had
like radio silence on that for a long
time and then jeff kelly tweeted like ah
yes yes let's go
you know
it feels it feels really good because uh
what we got was a really good beat em up
in our streets of rage yeah four yo
streets race four was oh my god
so we i want the beat-em-ups to come
back yeah i love them i i really do i
like just you know um people who really
didn't like battle two i love battle
toads uh if you go back and look at the
first belt i guess you have revisionist
history but this is better
100 times better
yeah please
so i i just want i can't wait i just i
just want to you know play i think you
already said it but final question was
um favorite console of all time i think
you already see it yeah yeah yeah ps2
just because of everything
gta prince of persia
like oh god of war like sly cooper all
these franchises was just i mean
fantasy yeah
fire man let's get into this poll
question and the rest of these topics
you know say shout out to kids he said
he spits man
last week's four results are headed the
people have spoken with more indie or
previous exclusive third-party games
from other platforms coming to game pass
are you more inclined to wait for them
to release in the service the winner at
52 of the vote was yes the value of game
pass is a no-brainer especially if the
game on the other platform is a time
exclusive coming in at second at 33
percent of the vote was the messy lords
i don't care y'all better boys doing
free labor for these developers
and in last place at 13 of the vote was
no i will not wait on a classic game of
the year contender i will buy it
regardless of platform group lord sub
what your thoughts on this sir
exactly frauds trucks
play the game play the game when it
comes out it's not a beta
look out for the pole coming at the uh
end of the show the new giant but uh we
got to get into some topics oh before we
do that
yeah
let's let's get there we started correct
correct uh we got [ __ ] 8127.5
this was triage they won't release
multiplayer separately and it'll be too
expensive delaying it labor and loss
momentum sucks but it's the best option
we will get into that momentarily so yes
sir
then we got ksanti five dollar super
chat salute to the panel love the real
talk right at the top uh king true
awards have not been spoken that is true
absolutely yes there we go
oh we got chicken
five dollar super chat [ __ ] that's the
shirt i want is it going on the store
unfortunately that is not good
you gotta look over at this you gotta
holla at the king king got me that
exclusive drip
they were so opposed to the camel oh
yeah you're right
it i was telling i said listen man i
gotta fish from something yeah yeah yeah
yeah
right people love them shirts yeah and
we got uh brett bingham five dollar
super chat people have already forgot
that halo 5 never got split screen and
people are complaining about a
three-month delay grow up shaking my
head
[Laughter]
replicant with the five pound super chat
shout out to everyone glad to be
catching the show live for once i
appreciate it man
he's playing the replicant
then we got gerald mack five dollar
splish hat
shout out to lord kingstradamus for
taking the high road and choosing to
educate instead of denigrating salute
listen i love my brother regardless to
what no doubt
so
next up king i need you to read this
it's from boondi 10 super chat i need
dragon tv 5 super chat shout out to the
lords and to work so hard on what we do
uh getting that media badge is like
getting a gold medal for your hard work
work play harder no doubt and we got
with the two dollar super chat salute
iop tony great to see you on that all
right
right there
then we got select bang with the four
dollar and fifty cents
and four pound and fifty
pence i guess whatever yeah
uh hello realm just want to say hello
keep up the great work cm punk baby oh
yeah okay okay wrestling thank thank god
go back to what you what you know thank
you
that's correct no no i'm getting your
face bastion and whatever he
saying with that last upgrade the member
you we need two more for that chivalry
yes
king i just pasted it into the chat hold
on a second i don't see it
there there it
might not play as much this season
because too much like why
they go on
have done it you know me and my voice i
could do it
he went he wanted me to read it because
i'm west indies
what else we had saw
uh we got a few more hold on a second
they got jumped of course i got you all
these dudes making
he can't do a wheelie on a unicycle he
counted to infinity twice
boom
back and i guess it's the book of action
uh then big shot i'll put the crush on
the chat for suicide kings upgrading
that membership to lord silva thank you
sir all right
did i miss something
no no he's saying two more that we need
to get that uh
yeah
if you thought the sea of thieves was
crazy the shivery jerk
developer extraordinaire how we doing
sir let's check your levels make sure
you're good
yeah yeah how do i sound no you're
smooth bro
that's what makes sure everything's good
so look at it you are up this is your
topic very controversial topic what's
going on around what's going on i
switched my topic so many times i don't
remember so yeah so you were
talking about halo infinite man looks
like um yeah it will be no longer the
co-op and the uh cooperative campaign
and the forge level editor will be
delayed you know that that's been going
around the news and interwebs so one to
set that off with you sir you know where
you're at is your topic
so uh
apparently
i highly doubt no one hasn't seen it but
halo infinite you know we got we got a
little bit of a little bit of a bump in
the road man when i say a bump in the
road
we won't be playing that with other
people man they want you to solo that
thing man they
they they they don't want they don't
want you to to share that game with
anyone man they want you to play that by
themselves and then not only is there no
co-op experience with hail infinite
launch
it looks like forge isn't gonna make it
at launch either it looks like it's
gonna be six months
three to six months three three months
on the cooperative experience and six
months on forge so i want to go to tony
first because uh he's the only person i
ain't really seen talk about this too
much uh tony what i want to hear from
you is like
as as far as a single player and a
multiplayer focus because i think forge
is
is a very important to halo in terms of
a multiplayer focus do you think that
this is like
i wouldn't say i think optically it does
make it look bad but how do you feel on
when you first read this
yeah all right so i'll take it back a
little bit because this news popped off
on friday right yeah i was out you know
going back to my boy uh jeffrey we're
our drinking and stuff you know just
because we don't do that too often so i
get back and people like yo tony why are
you being so quiet about this halo news
like what halo knows what happened right
so
and it was my boy carlos who told me
this right and i look i'm like oh that's
the point because you know going back a
little bit i never i mean i i played the
first first halo back when it first came
out but i'm like i'm being honest the
twin strike stuff was like i'm like
what's going on here yeah like it just
didn't make any sense to me so i'm like
i'm not playing any games that are like
this this is too much but ironically uh
the ps3 360 uh every game was that fps
game so it kind of forced me to do that
right
since we're talking about exactly what
happened when you found out yeah let me
tell you real quick tony how i found out
obviously
kid smith calls me to super chat by the
way super chat
i i look at my phone like because i work
i work graveyard [ __ ] so yeah so kid
knows not to call me at this time we
ain't gonna go into that but so i look
at this i'm like
man what does he want so i pick i i i i
answer he's like dude i need a thumbnail
i'm like what do you mean you need a
thumbnail he's like i need it on the
halo subject i'm like what happened with
halo
he was like he told me i was like
damn
i was like i'll get to it man but sorry
tony i just yeah
anyway so so again i i hadn't played the
halos because the first one was a little
bit too complicated for me but when i
got my when i found my first xbox i got
as soon as i started getting money in
the decision i'm like i'm biting xbox
right now right so i i was like let me
start playing the halos all through
because i saw infant was coming this was
like a couple years ago right like
there's gonna be a halo that's gonna be
coming too it wasn't called if at that
point so my homie carl was like yo why
don't we just play through all these
games me and you through the whole
campaign you as a newcomer me as a
veteran right so we've been doing co-op
this entire time so carl's like yo man
we've been doing all this stuff with
halo now we can't play infinite because
ain't got no
you know
and like yes i realize i can play the
game by itself right but i'm like to me
you know my halo experience has always
been me and my homie carlos right so i
will just wait right because i could do
that it's going to be a game pass right
i will wait to play that campaign but it
is disappointing because that's always
been a central thing with hillary the
first time i play hillary like i said
when it was really confusing it was me
and one of my boys were playing it and
that's just part of the experience so
while it is disappointing i i don't want
to be one of these people that's like
yelling or whatever because i understand
it's either this or delay the game we
don't want that we want the game now
microsoft needs this right now you know
a lot of people um
they clown microsoft about this but it
is true it's like you guys don't have an
exclusive right now for your new console
you need something that's going to draw
people in so
while it is disappointing right yes
release it as it is now and yeah it
would force that because i know you know
you get to build stuff for me i don't
really care about that so it's not a
loss for me but as long as the core
multiplayer is there where the betas
went off it went off really really well
and stuff as long as you have the that
and you have the single player you're
gonna be okay and then you'll get your
co-op later and i'm gonna just hope that
by the time it happens we'll also get
more you know additional extra content
we could enjoy with friends or whatever
you know what i'm saying so
again i i'm disappointed but i'm not
gonna sweat it too much because i know
it's gonna come eventually because the
alternative would just be another delay
and we've seen too many games late for
for obvious reasons the ronin all this
other stuff i get it and nobody wants to
repeat cyberpunk you know
i understand that by the way i find it
funny how in the end halo infinite came
out as the hero in that by deciding to
just delay their game imagine if that
game would have came out as is last year
yeah
it would yeah it would have been a
disaster so the delay was good but i
don't think we could get another lay
especially since we know for a fact the
game is effectively done they just had
to do a couple little tweaks here so i'm
okay with that i'm disappointed but i'm
okay with it no doubt let's get lord
three bit in the round you know what i'm
saying my man for the vghd podcast
developer animator extraordinaire what's
going on brother
hey i'm doing good man no doubt so let's
get your feeling max obviously i saw
some things on your timeline
i like to have balanced discussion you
know all around so what's your feeling
on this whole thing you know with halo
infinite the co-op campaign not being
there at launch as well as forge as well
as forge
yeah i try to reel in like what i like i
guess my own personal thoughts because i
get very emotional when it comes to halo
i'm just like come on
um but you know i've heard so many
different mixed opinions coming in from
the community about this and
most of my friends are like hey this is
not a big deal
uh it's it's i'll wait three months
after launch to play or experience co-op
as long as it's announced when i can
play it and most of their perspective
does come from them wanting the game
like i want it now right um but i'm sort
of on the boat where uh on launch i
think the game should be what it's
initially meant to be not just features
you're implying that it needs to be
complete sir yes yeah
i'm in that boat you know i i gotta bet
this one i don't care
i already know what you were you wearing
your segment selfish reason
it's my money i'm selfish and i need
somebody needs
to continue three minutes
he's selfish
i mean now yeah i definitely want to
hear what everybody thinks about this
because i'm constantly just thinking
about it but i think um
you know i think if anything regardless
halo infinite is going to launch
and many many gamers uh many people
including me is going to play right and
enjoy it um i'm not contributing any
um of my thoughts like
with the state of the game to a success
success right now i think um i just
personally i just hate the philosophy of
release the game quickly and fix it
later um it's it's literally the the
ammo that people are using game pass
with right they're saying game pass will
lead to more broken games but we we've
seen the fix it later mentality more and
more in this generation uh now that
patches are more of a thing right um and
i feel like it can be abused sometimes
in the gaming industry
yeah more sales like cyberpunk right
we've seen that whole thing avengers
versus spiderman you know
yeah i don't think it came out okay
you just don't acknowledge it until it's
a next-gen patch yes
and even in 343's case with the mcc
collection uh when it first came out
right and halo 5 and launching uh
lacking content and
being kind of broken in certain areas to
try and make that date so i'm not saying
this will happen in 343's case but this
did happen with them in the past to be
fair right and if devs are saying they
need more time and and microsoft is not
giving it to them it's more about the
money at that point and not the product
itself and i'm always about like quality
in the product and i always i i
understand the messaging and the
ramifications of a delay like that would
be pretty bad another like oh another
delay right wouldn't be the best
especially if they have like
sponsorships or anything but how much
money we got to give you to get the game
done like how much money how much money
and time do we need to sink into you
before you finish the product like how
much do we got to hear oh you know i
need this weekend uh maybe on friday uh
you know i i know we was we were working
on the ankles animation and it's not
right listening
i think pressure to king's point i think
it is fair like having pressure as a
studio can be good sometimes right
having internal deadlines
something to work for can be a good
thing especially i've been in different
development situations where um you know
they will sort of relax if you guys
don't have a deadline
certain things become more important
right for sure when you do have a
deadline that that is that's definitely
fair
um i i just think that
there are there's been um throughout the
production pipeline different things 343
has just sort of been saying like oh we
took out the weather we don't have time
to put in a little weather game you know
just just like oh we don't have time no
raid racing
i'm just like at this point i'm just you
know i'm in the boat where i just want
when i play the game when i turn on the
game i want it initially to experience
that game with other people you know
with my friends and stuff like that i'm
fine with it um
not fine with it but i i understand like
why they're doing it but
halo has always been that pillar
uh game that i love experiencing with
other people like halo 1
i played that with my dad growing up and
absolutely in
halo 2 played that with my sisters so
it's like that that thing and now
everyone is it's covered right so
most of uh the people you're playing
with online before before you have
players like yo yes everybody's live is
cracking you know
we we do this they do this and they
sleep we good and then we hear it you
like what
i think they said what genetically and
then i go back to three that asked me a
question after you add it
i think when it comes down to it
it's like look like
i would prefer them to do this state of
decay like it's just like look the
multiplayer don't work a lot with the
co-op experience like don't don't put it
out there yet like
imagine like you know state of decay
probably would have reviewed better if
if they would have like yo
you got to play by yourself
because
that multiplayer portion is still jacked
up like yeah
and a lot of people that played it by
themselves they had a better experience
and it's just like you know like
i do feel like this is bad optics in
terms of of three four three because all
it looks like it's okay three four three
drops the ball again right but it's just
like you know like
my thing is like people want to blame
something like this on game pass well
this was this is being done in in
multiple genres not in game pass yeah
this is being done this was being done
before game pass with microsoft products
right forge wasn't a hey it wasn't in
halo 5 at launch right the quest the
question i want to add just interrupt
one quick question because you're making
a good point the the question i want to
ask all of you is that you know when
joseph uh state and always butchers the
state in staten state right so when he
comes out and he says um you know he
talks about the delay and then he
mentions because it's a live service
game right you know that we feel that we
can that a live service game is really
never finished and that you have a
foundation and then you build upon it
like does does that affect you three bit
does that affect you like does that
factor you tony when you hear these kind
of statements in reference to live
service then saying that we can add
something else later that's feature
missing
it's just yeah okay
it just depends on how the live service
is done okay if they give me
like
one when you know
people bring up oh you know destiny does
it does it well acting like destiny
didn't have crazy learning curves at the
beginning of destiny's life cycle like i
if if they give me
like i'm worried about the single player
i'm not worried about the multiplayer
like and i'm worried about how they're
going to handle
telling all the variables that is in
halo right now you know you got the
cortana you got the flood coming back in
in halo wars you got the banish
apparently winning a war like you got
the whole cortana thing like it to me
it's just like look like
you got to tell me a vanilla halo
infinite has got to have a beginning
middle and end right and that's the
biggest thing because it's just like
you destiny didn't get that that pass
you're not going to get that pass either
right so okay and i was going to i was
one tony and three but to ask answer the
same question in reference to joseph
staton's comments about live service
games and attitudes yeah yeah but by the
way you know i'm pretty sure some guys
could agree with this like i have a
visceral reaction when i hear live
surface
you know what i'm saying um but here's
the thing
but at least this game told you up front
it is a live service type of game
infinite is there for a reason right so
i understand that yes we will be getting
additional content throughout the life
of this game however long it lasts i get
that but at the same time i can and i'm
saying this as a person who's like take
your time with it
coop's been there since day one so i
think people have a right to be upset
about that like that [ __ ] in my opinion
that should not be a feature that needs
to be added on later like again i
understand the reasons why but it should
not be it should be there day one like
all the other stuff whatever you plan to
do you know specifically if it's like
community driven
fine that i get that infinite i
understand that but that should have
been their day one man you know
i mean we just came off a one-year delay
prior
exactly which was you know at the time
said to the you know to make the game
better right they said that was the fix
craig face
shout out to my man chris
they was proud of craig too which is
kind of funny but yeah i mean i i hear
what you're saying i i want to get three
bit again on it on the jumpsuit that was
done so i i sent my pieces okay cool
yeah um
as long as when you with in halo's case
if you're making a live service type
game with the halo name
there
should be it shouldn't be an excuse to
cut out things just because you're
saying it's a live service i don't
necessarily agree with that like not
necessarily like it should be excused i
don't think they're using any excuse i
think they're just being realistic
they're being transparent like look yeah
it's either delay the game i i don't
think like when they said that you know
they're going to put it with the road
map i don't necessarily think they were
like i thought okay we're going to make
road maps and seasons more appealing to
get it to pick up because it's gonna
it's gonna be part of that i think they
were like look this is the time frame
it's gonna be part of this season like i
don't think it's something that they're
like yo season two gonna have forge in
it all right you're gonna sell season
two because season two's getting four
it's like i think it was mainly like
okay
season two is really room we're probably
gonna drop forge and you're just gonna
get that experience during that season
with the forge no no continued yeah
and and to be fair they did like release
a time frame for forge and also co-op
correct
um i just think when i think about halo
i think about
halo already has so much inside of it
when you really think about it of how
big of a sandbox game
is
you have the theater mode like there are
people who are who just experience
specific parts of halo and that's their
thing
so um when you are releasing halo and
it's it's more of an event right you're
really seeing the forge mode the theater
mode uh you have your big team battle
you have everything um so
live service uh games can actually
really contribute to that even further
right um i i do think for sure let me
ask you a question three bit um
i've always said
franchises that have multiple uh you
know games in it like such as halo
i feel like it's harder for them to keep
everything realistic because they keep
implying you know
let's put firefighting here let's put
warzone in here let's put arena in here
let's put uh theater in here let's put
forge in here and i feel like do you
feel like
just because they keep adding it as the
time goes by more franchises with halo
that you're entitled to that mode in the
next one no
that's a good question
um
where or halo kind of put themselves in
that boat
based on what they offered initially
from the beginning right yeah because
when you think about a sequel or you're
thinking about them adding to what's
already there
and then continuing and making it better
and better so
yeah kind of i mean i know it's it's
hard they put themselves in a weird
situation where they it has so much
inside of halo um which is why they
probably need to delay things and in
halo
development i do not envy at all because
all the stuff within halo is
way more than a lot of other games i
will say that for sure let me get on
solving because i'm very curious about
my bro here he's the the lord of single
player uh i am very curious we have not
spoken this is going to be raw reactions
on this
congress solve when the news broke
co-op campaign
is not gonna be a part as well as forge
we keep forgetting forge forge is also
not there like what was your thought
thought process in reference to this
uh so here on iop we have something
called uh addict's world oh we're gonna
pull the star's world on us
this is solves world damn damn i don't i
don't give a rap about either
either one of those
november 15 fdw let's go
let's go
here we go here we go we can save what
we want but it regardless
yeah
exactly listen i understand
people's uh people have engaged with
this game specifically in that way in
terms of the co-op for a very long time
i get that
um
that's not the way i engage with it like
when i talk about the multiplayer aspect
of halo from the very beginning halo 1
it's always been competitive multiplayer
right i didn't
when we got halo 1 i was already living
on my own by myself i didn't have
somebody on the couch to play with me so
you know the campaign is something that
i always played by myself
and then over the years that's what i've
gravitated to doing because of specific
things right i'll give a shout out to bg
because bg put out a video that
basically echoes everything that i feel
about why
i i'm not a big fan of co-op
and
putting cocktails
in his thumbnails yeah vpg thumbnails is
very funny i like the facial expressions
um
but basically when it comes to
co-op in a campaign based game a story
based campaign
um for me i gaming is a very selfish
thing i like to engross myself
completely into the campaign and the
characters meaning i like to turn the
lights off put my headphones on be
engrossed bonza's calling you heartless
at the chat continue that's fine
when when you when you play a game that
has that aspect and then you just tack
on another player right you tack on
another player
it takes you out of that moment because
you know in my mind there's master chief
not master chiefs
and friends
exactly so it doesn't it doesn't appeal
to me and another thing that that that
bg mentioned that i echo completely 100
this is another thing there's times when
you want to like you get to a cut scene
or something like that you want to take
your time listen to cutscene read it
whatever the case may be this other
person you know reads a mile a minute or
doesn't care about it clicks through it
and all of a sudden all of a sudden that
immersion is gone but whose fault is
that song is that your friend's fault is
that the game's full that is
let me shout out my little brother
no but again but it's it's a condition
of playing it with someone else right
that is just it just
the pace is different everything is
different about it i just want to point
out every from now on every time i do an
addict world here we go from now on
every time i do an attitude i don't want
to hear
saul pulling up like but addict this
like from now on when i say i don't care
what anyone in the chat wants i want
what i want but i want to hear saul say
that's fine addict no because
that actually because my worlds are
reasonable oh
here's the thing though here's the thing
in addict's world i don't care about
saul's world
i'm still reasonable you're not you're
unreasonable all the time
let's break this down
that something that's been in halo
for for decades that's reasonable to you
yeah i don't care about it never exactly
it it never existed for me like okay
okay okay i rest the case i'll rest my
kids okay so don't worry about this
i got you
so i listen and i understand people's
beef over i really do but at the at this
point of the game mm-hmm at this point
you're going
if the game is still broken right in
certain aspects and not content complete
feature complete like if you release
this game this holiday right and the
aspects of it that are still broken and
you didn't delay the game that's a
problem when you're telling me the
game's going to be fine it's ready to go
it just doesn't have these features in
it
and it's not a polished
problem or issue
release the game this year honestly um i
understand i understand that for some
people the moment they throw the game on
it's co-op i get it i get it um but if
the game is not
broken and not ready to go if it's ready
to go in terms of polish
i feel the game should come out another
thing is a lot of people don't think
about this when it comes to
the logistics
my
by the way real quick we do have enough
now to officially do yes
we're going to do that stream
have such a great time
so so one other thing we don't think
about logistically when it comes to the
fact that halo infinite is a different
type of game than past halos
when it comes to implementing uh
co-op
it's they haven't really told us how the
campaign plays out right right is the
campaign our campaign missions just out
in the open world or when you click
right or when you click on a campaign
mission right do you get sort of
transported to the mission area whatever
the case may be like yesterday i think
it's right beyond the map you click it
and then it goes into it yeah so the
thing about that is okay how do they
handle the tethering of of two players
right where where are the limits there
right so there's a lot of logistics
stuff that if they're just focusing on
finishing the game might fall to the
wayside so for me it's obvious that they
don't have it the way they want it to be
correct um so this and it's a different
thing this destiny this destiny this uh
this halo is a bigger you said than ever
yeah
he's gave me a bomb for future eyes
which is almost every podcast
i could say
i could say look saul i got receipts i
was i was selfish once
that's fine that's all it takes man
so for me like
yeah so that to me it's obvious that
there are kinks there that really have
to be worked out that if they would have
really released that now there would be
issues right we've seen kind of broken
multiplayer in a few like we have seen
the ascent we've seen like uh dark
alliance we've seen a few
so just just get it right i understand
people's beef
but at the end of the day i i think this
is not something that you delay a game
over i think that you know i i just
don't i just really don't so if the game
is ready to go before i pass it the kick
my question is i haven't went yet oh but
it's your time but you start it off
no i didn't i i gave it i gave it to
tony
king likes to to pull the king card on
his topic all right google google all
right so let me just ask this question
before i pull it over
he interrupted everyone he interrupted
everybody
the question i have for you is what i
hear your points right and you're saying
for you single player soft
you know this ain't really a fact or
nothing this should not
um stop the release of the game right so
my question to you is
what's the downside you're gonna like
the poll question but what's the
downside to delaying it for you
for me yes i mean
they've
they haven't given a date from the very
beginning right they didn't want it they
didn't want to give you a date and not
be 100 sure of it but they have been
adamant about this year right
um i i think when we look at the
development cycle of this game it's you
cannot
say that this game has not been through
some hell oh yeah it's obvious it is
obvious they've tried their best to not
bring that to the forefront it's been
impossible to do right we know what's we
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes but we know it hasn't been great
um
at this point
you got people excited over the
multiplayer you have that that kind of
momentum you have people that are cod
fans you have people that battlefield
fans talk about i'm still playing halo
like i'm excited for halo
to delay it again for this again for for
a reason that isn't quality based right
to delay it for that reason i don't
think makes sense i think
when you when you weigh the positives of
being able to release this game on or
close to its 20-year anniversary with
the biggest halo ever with hopefully an
amazing campaign with multiplayer that's
available to millions upon millions of
people free to play um i think the pros
of releasing it without those uh
features outweigh the cons i really do
okay attic linking
look
as much as i was cap and i agree or so
um i feel like
look i want this to be because i i you
know i play halo 5 with kid smooth i
played halo 4 with my friend my cousin
sage but it's just like
there's a difference between
missing a whole mode and missing a
feature right it's not like it's not
there it's going to be there i i would
prefer to be there day one
but
uh you know normally i would be like
look
i don't care
what or what what you know the
multiplayer people want i want to play
but it's just like at the end of the day
it's like who am i to say because i want
to play with my brother that the people
who could play by themselves can't play
already right so it's just like to me
you know
i'm not gonna not play it either like
i'm not gonna wait for everyone in here
regardless of what happened yeah i feel
for the most part is going to play right
we all we would all agree right anybody
anyone that's taking a stance that
they're not going to play it if the
joint is delayed because i think we're
all in agreement right yeah i think
we're all good okay
we're fighting we're fraud
and when it comes down to it's like look
like the biggest important thing here is
they acknowledge the issue right they
didn't just try to throw that out there
and be like oh the multiplayer is messed
up the co-op is messed up like they're
like look we don't want to to hurt it we
we're going to delay that because they
think about how crazy
it they up there in 343 they're like yo
we're gonna have to announce that we're
gonna do we have to delay the co-op
experience like like that is a big thing
to do like
i i in at this point it's like look like
we've seen stuff like this in the past
gta 5 launch of single player only and
then like like 30 days later or launch
with multiplayer and for two or three
weeks multiplayer didn't even work so
it's just like like at the end of the
day like
we give plenty of other people the past
when it comes to stuff like this
uh you know for instance the last of us
had a very popular uh factions
multiplayer and it was delayed in the
second one so it's just like look like i
want it there
well you get what i'm saying
i want that day one but at the end of
the day like if the game is functional
when it was working but that co-op
experience doesn't work i don't think
it's worth delaying it from that actual
feature
i think if anything you know forge being
six months is more of an issue than
co-op being three months
yeah because because after the end of
the day that that forge is going to
breathe life into the multiplayer that's
the biggest issue
but you know i would like to play with
more
than just you know myself but at the end
of the day like i'm still going to enjoy
it so i can't really say i'm not going
to play it lord
one thing before we go to kingdom that i
forgot to mention yes
this whole thing of joseph stanton
calling it a live service game
i don't really vibe with that like me
neither
listen the multiplayer for sure right
the free to play multiplayer
yeah yeah yeah i'm just saying i don't
know
what it was where have you been i told
y'all it was going to be that way we're
going in game play no no i know i'm not
saying i'm not saying about that i'm
saying that that's not really what that
game is like
i can under i can understand this
question i can understand what for years
we know this no no no what i'm saying is
this the multiplayer aspect is that
right a hundred percent that's what it
is right no the game it's a single
player right but the single player
aspect the thing about it is all right
so what do you mean by live service am i
am i going to see mad masters
am i going to see mad master chiefs
running around my world you know it's
going to be yours so what is it around
and you're going to be it's going to be
a live world for you but it's good
but it's still a closed off garden so so
to me that's the thing like
we don't know what it is we might not
see i always got you want to pass you on
the screen
you might not see that and you might do
see it but
you just go do you believe that's what
it is do you believe that's what it is
listen i don't know
like like they didn't sit down and tell
us exactly what it is so there was your
partner is really cut i'm not looking at
that right i delete all that out of my
dna
don't do that i do want to throw that
leak that happened last year
that said that atriox had his own well
forget forget it but
right what i want to talk about we're
doing that
you know three bit you know obviously i
crave a question no i wasn't talking
about the least right that just happened
okay because there's there is a rumor
from the uh
343 that has did an unspoken account on
reddit and the gist of it uh three bit
was kind of like they already knew the
campaign internally again rumor
speculation no one's saying that we
don't know if this is true so i'm a
caveat do not be acting like this is
official i'm just saying what came
across online right was the effect that
you know the campaign they internally
the studio knew it was far
you know worse in the worst day as far
as the mechanics of co-op and making
decisions as far as you know whether it
going to be people tethered and or you
know just the structure of it right
you you want are you cool to speak on
that or three bit or you want to leave
that alone yeah okay i'll speak on a
little bit without like going yeah
yeah um
yeah so what i was posting about earlier
was like yeah i i
like the
delaying the co-op is one thing but what
this developer was kind of saying is
like hey we need more time on the
campaign itself
and that's how i'm like okay delay the
game that's when i was like okay just go
ahead delay the game if you guys need
more time
on the game itself fire just fire him
now
because yeah the the co-op thing when he
was when he was mentioning
um the the checkpoint system that
they're trying to figure that out it's
kind of a nightmare right now
that's when i was like okay um
i can see that like you have four people
in this open world type game and
initially they were thinking about
everyone can do
uh like be on their own path right and
then be completely separate but how does
that work with czech bungie if you do
that right so
um yeah so i guess they're figuring that
out and um
and
the co-op if anyone is thinking like oh
the co-op has um is the only thing
that's probably being affected from this
and it's not in tandem with other
potential things like in game
development that's just you know that's
it's not a light switch i'm gonna quote
the one paragraph of the rumored
developer you know as far as he said you
know look to be blunt it's buggy it's
buggy as hell and then some he said
between these two as far as forging
campaign campaign co-op is a mess and
downright unplayable but there's no way
in hell we are going to be allowed to
delay the launch by the powers that be
delaying the campaign altogether was
severely considered with a multiplayer
only launch but the suits told us
straight no the game will ship with a
paid campaign come hell or high water
and we can pay it back over time at the
very best i can guarantee that whilst
there is some crunch going on it's far
from the most inhumane thing i've seen
working in the industry a far cry from
something like cd projekt red cyberpunk
morale is high even after this we think
it's going to be a great game but i do
wish we could cook the campaign a little
longer
that's when i when i heard that i was
just like delay because um i mean it's
not going to get delayed i'll play it
regardless we all love halo i'm pretty
sure everyone on the panel loves halo
course um and if you're just cutting it
like and i agree with what saab said
like if you're if it's just
you're just cutting out the co-op that's
i don't think that's worth delaying the
whole game for even though i love
i love freaking playing co-op and all
that and that's that's just me um but if
you're having trouble with like the like
taking out like big sections of the game
or you're just different features within
the campaign that you're just like it's
getting buggy and you just need more
time and you just need more time yeah
all right you don't get no more time
shows and i'm spending this money
broadway
she need these shoes she need this she
need that you you ain't getting no more
time it's tuesday but she ain't right
she you can't have her outside looking
crazy we going to the boom boom room
first first caveat
so we know i got a horse in this race
yeah i know you got a hunch in this race
you want this game to release because he
gonna lose that horizon for the better
west back with you november 15th baby
i knew horizon was gonna be pushed right
right now this developer i hate these
unsourced dudes these dudes that's not
gonna give their days
you you have enough mouth to talk put
your name on it
put your name on it don't don't
play no games with this we don't know
who you are oh we know you joe blow in
the back with a playstation
i don't care what you say i don't trust
you i don't believe you because you're
gonna sit there and tell me this but
it's okay it's cool it's cool i don't
care first of all i don't care about
forge at no point in time have i ever
said let me build a level and have fun
there are millions who
this is the part where i don't care
do you care about just to clarify i care
that was never my thing i never sat
there and said let's craft the world i
like to go play my games i don't like to
build my game
if that i would be playing dreams right
i would be playing one of the best uh
build the game build a beer games in the
world
i don't care for no forage okay so when
when dudes it's like it's six months out
so
what about co-op campaign sir now there
you go yes right now the first time i
play halo i'm playing it alone
i'm playing it in the dark with my
headphones on
i want to feel every bit of the emotion
where katana what i want to know what's
going on
like you know sovereignness i mute
people i shut your chat like i don't
want to hear you talking
so i really detach from individuals and
i play my s that to me halo is a single
player game
i am master chief me
right it's not master chief in the chief
vets right we're not doing it right we
are not doing this i don't care i don't
care about cranking it up to a doom
level with all these little skulls just
because i want to pass it with my boys
just to say i did it on the hardest
level so he could pick me up when i drop
that's the only reason why you won't
because you want to because it existed
every halo
when i when i played by myself it didn't
exist you know every time for me
it existed after i finished the campaign
so when somebody jumps in and they want
to skip a scream man could you imagine
you skipping a screen on my new game
i'm booting you i'm booting you straight
out and i'm going back to play that
mission over you getting the hell out of
here i'll probably might delete you off
my friend's list
that's not gonna happen well anyway
that's not an egregious thing now
more of egregious thing if they say it's
something like the story is incomplete
yeah
like
all this doom and gloom around this
stuff
i'ma have to call frauds wow all right
until you give me your receipts until
you put your name on this list boy i
don't want to hear from you like i come
from
if it's real
stick your name on it okay so he's
supposed to put his name out yeah
you know why you know why just like he
said the powers that be this coming out
tuesday right they're coming out tuesday
so he knows the powers that beat by
you want to sit there you want to leak
stuff who's this leaker like who is this
we don't care about that
the game is going to come out and and
listen anybody that feels away forge is
not there see you in six months
anybody that feels that uh co-op is not
there to see you in two to three months
whatever they said they're gonna give it
to you you get it then and this is the
great thing about choice right
you're not forced none of this stuff is
forced you don't really have to force to
go out and buy it if you have game pass
you can just download it and try it if
if you don't have game pass and you
don't feel like the game is up to snuff
for what you want after you listen to
your favorite reviewer of the game
because pretty sure everybody's going to
be reviewing this game and i encourage
everyone to go to you know your acg's
your uh
attic you know go go to everybody that
you trust listen to what they say about
the game and then you know try it you
know i don't i'm not into that um that
media uh stuff that uh
uh the metacritic i'm not i don't care
about that i care about listening to
people that i actually trust so if they
play the game and the game is really
good and they like it then buy it you
know um
there's choice here guys and this
holiday is going to be stacked so
them not having co-op i don't care
because it really doesn't affect me in
that manner them having force it
definitely never affects me i do not
care at all
so
the game is coming out
good that's it everything that i care
about is there that's all i care about i
don't care about anything else fair
all right i'm jumping because y'all
driving me crazy oh
look man
i ain't feeling it i ain't feeling it
i'm gonna be the enemy i'll be the evil
dude in the room um you know look i get
it i hear the points you know
single player
you you know a lot of people say you
know look at the statistics you know a
lot of people don't play the co-op in
that and fair fair the my only counter
to to the people who say
that they just playing single player
okay is that again this is a franchise
that the core pillars have been co-op
the single player and the multiplayer
right so to me
you are shipping a major core pillar
missing right that's a feature that is
missing to me right we've already had
six years we've been waiting for this
game right then last time we saw them
which was the series x release right
it's not going to make launch everybody
said great you know but we rather the
game be delayed i'm just confused
with every other time we hear a
developer say yo we got to delay the
game everybody says good great we want
the best version of the game
for this game okay
it like put it to you this way king like
imagine if like the net like the witch
queen came out and they said yo
something's wrong with the
the cross plate messed everything up you
got to do the whole story by yourself
my point is delay the game
so at the end of the day if again if
it's a a feature that has been in every
prior iteration right
and now for whatever reason you can't
hit it and we just came off of a
one-year delay right to me that shows
there are deeper issues going in and i'm
not really feeling this whole live
service and game pass and we because to
me it starts to spread a narrative that
you can now put something that has a
feature missing right and then okay we
afford it to give you this later let me
let me say this to you guys yeah
this is exactly what i talked about what
i've seen and that was the trend right
the developers have always we're going
to patch we're going to patch we're
going to pack we got to the point right
now that we go to reddit and we go to
these things to get patch notes you know
we go to these sites after the fact that
the game came out and we clowned
nintendo a lot
for all they did just give you the name
of the game but the game don't come out
for 10 years right right we found them a
lot but when that game came out it was
complete right very until this recent
era they might get a update or a patch
on certain things but nintendo shipped
complete games when they were
comfortable right right now we got to
the point now where with this online
stuff developers are able to and this is
the board's room because the boardroom
doesn't care that's what i was going
don't care about it that to me is what
this is to me
what this is is the boardroom has won
the argument right the board
internally has said
because look let me tell you something i
like to buy i like to buy game geek drip
and all that all the time right right if
you go to the xbox gear store right and
you try to buy the halo 20th anniversary
drip that fly joint with the number 20
with master chief everything associated
with them
it is sold out it's been sold out for
months right
that to me and i listen i want the game
listen i'm not going to cap of course
when the game comes out i'm going to
play it regardless that's not the issue
my issue is i just don't like the lack
of empathy for a feature that a lot of
people have brought accustomed to
playing with their friends that's my
issue at launch it's no empathy it's
like well so what i don't care and it's
just like at the end of the day here's
the other point well who's the the lack
of empathy coming from besides myself
well no i'm just saying yeah
i want to get to the crux of what what
cog is saying right do you feel like the
lack of empathy is coming from the board
no no no i feel like the lack of empathy
is coming from gamers to other gamers
you know but they just want the game
because they just want to get and i get
it i want the game too we've been
waiting i would i get it but here's my
other point people say oh it's three
months right no big deal but for the
person who loves that mode
the campaign's gonna be finished and
spoiled so you you've lost the incentive
to give somebody something three months
later
unless you're telling me in three months
you're gonna give you're gonna pull a
hive busters are you gonna give us some
different campaign extra new thing to go
back to to be excited to but at that
point three months everybody done
finished the game beat the game there is
no excitement to playing it at that
point that's what i'm saying so
yeah i'm selfishly it hurts like i'm not
gonna lie like it really look i'm a
person that even if something affects me
if it's for the greater good of the game
i'll put my personal thing aside and say
okay all i'm saying with this is i just
don't understand every other game we say
delays are good we use the mayamato
quote three bit right we'd be like
delays are good but halo for some reason
nah i gotta come out this year fan and
i'm like
the delay is fine again if the game is
still broken
that's fine like delay the game as much
as you need to delay the game the game
ain't working right right if you're
telling me the game functions fine it's
just going to be missing these aspects
of it then the game isn't broken i
understand that i understand you
understand so there's a difference
between it being incomplete right and
not functioning properly
we just gave them a year
and it goes back to it it goes back to
the to the idea that the things going on
behind the scenes with this game right
so which leads me to believe there are
bigger problems because i don't believe
that
all
right
you can't just be the co-op like you're
just thinking like oh they're just
turning off the co-op and then
everything else
that's a tinfoil hat situation like we
listen all right forget forget you
forget you don't know we don't know we
can't forget i mean
we outside i get it but at the end of
the day right
if we
saw craig
we saw no roach ray tracing
we saw clipping in the joint
right let's be real we saw all these
things right so we can't act like
there's not some development things
going on
right that's all i'm saying i think if
the okay shout out to the community for
craigface right shout out for the to the
community because i was sitting there
eating that jordan i'll give you a hell
of a ship and i was gonna play it right
and then the developers would have did
what they said what they gonna do right
now right they're gonna
they're gonna update apache they're
gonna update patrick so i'm gonna update
patch dude i've been playing i'd have
been listening but i don't have that the
energy
for cyberpunk right you know like no i'm
not going to buy it yeah but when it's
something
we can't that's what i'm saying but look
i'm sitting there right yeah
they said no ray chase i didn't see that
i thought i saw ray chasing but i really
didn't know but then until he showed me
craig face so they had to fix the craig
face craig face took a year off right so
i'm pretty sure the next time we see
halo craig face will be fixed and i
think they took a whole year on
craigslist no no i'm pretty sure we're
not gonna get that and i'm pretty sure
that whole year craig face is gonna be
fixed there's other aspects to this
problem that we that they're
experiencing and they're trying to uh
bolt down to it right i think they're
trying to give the game longevity yeah
of course of course they they're they're
going to fix these little issues and
that will give it a little bit more
three months down the line people run
back into it you see another i feel that
i feel everything's on the line i feel
everything you're talking about i know
where you're going i just my concern and
this is for tony this for three bit and
i see you kiss move i got you is my
concern is there's a narrative that
normally i don't feed into that i have
seen right which is
it's on game pass so you you're good you
know and i think we are that's what i'm
worried about because now this is a
chief example of a first party game
missing something or maybe launching we
came off the ascent
outriders
we're starting to develop ammunition
for this narrative that we say don't
exist
that's my thing it's launched the game
but yo you might not have an arm in the
night have a leg this week you know
launch the game you might not have
anything
launched the game but you ain't gonna
have the multiplayer this this one and i
remember from cuphead
i'm still waiting for cuphead to give me
co-op or or cup remember
remember when the dev said co-ops coming
yeah yeah you're right so come on we
can't we can't actually like you know
what i said yeah good i do i brought kid
in here because i'm about to take off no
i don't know i i'm
i just wanted to say something real
quick because i i'm gonna miss the topic
yeah uh look everyone in the chat i love
12 minutes i don't want people think
like
great game definitely go check that out
phenomenal thing me me and cog share pre
except for something i'll get my balls
fixed but i definitely appreciate
everything coming through actually kid
smooth beat it he beat all of it so
i appreciate it everyone take me off the
edge man i'm hot i'm in my feelings
save me off the edge kid
no like i i want to comment on like halo
and like i i agree with mo multiple
points because obviously i came off a
little hot after the news like i said
the first thing i know what you said oh
okay called and i'm like yo man
what's going on
so um but
after more like stuff came out and then
watching people like randy pitchfork and
stuff come out and whatnot the one thing
i did that we did
i did forget about this though and it
did bring me back to stay say the k2 is
that this campaign is different yes yes
you're shooting for more of an open
world
um concept and
according to that leaker
which coincides with what homie uh uh
dang what is his name that always an
xbox live parties with us jansen what's
up because he has a buddy yeah and he it
was like it was like well we don't know
how you know to fix the spawning issues
right like because you know when halo
somebody dies you got to wait until
somebody gets right area and whatnot but
if everybody gets to split up in
different areas it's like
ambitious yeah that's very ambitious oh
it's like
and and i wonder when we first when that
the rumors of it being open world itself
i was like well how is co-op going to
work is it going to be the same co-op
because i remember i did a video on
hillary and i was like hey maybe the
campaign is going to be the campaign but
a co-op experience is going to be
different
maybe more like destiny or something
like that where you're doing this
specifically this is more set up for
like you know co-op modes but maybe the
campaign might be dull maybe that's why
they giving you that that that dude that
is who's gonna be with you right right
right buddy dude
yeah so that's why i always saw i was
under the impression that that the
traditional co-op probably wouldn't be
there right and um
but obviously every halo i played was
through online co-op like me too attic
halo 5 guardians yeah it's tradition
it's tradition 8 33 a.m
we really united it so it's
disappointing but i did understand like
i looked at it i'm like well
i i'm not going gonna be too upset
because if this to the point where it's
like there's just issues that just
doesn't make it work right um
whatever you know what i mean but it's
but you still you think about the
narratives out there well game pass oh
it's
they're peace smelling it that's the
thing that really bothers me about it
it's like i'm not getting a full
fledging experience plus i got this
argue i gotta keep arguing about game
pass and how it's not delivering broken
or unfit games and like can i ask you a
question yes please do you think this
thing is tied to that xbox one x crap
like the that's the fact that that's a
valid point that's a valid point
cut them out and just cut them out and
throw them away no no they shouldn't
because then i have to give
but listen that that's a valid point and
antoine let me get tony um you know with
the development what is it how many co
how many variants of of halo infinite
right base xbox one
s
scorpio
this is what i'm saying
if he is the problem why don't we cut
out the root of the problem listen no no
get rid of that segment of the
population but you know what they can't
right right because they already said he
was doing it
now i don't care about what you said you
could turn your back on what you said at
any day give a reason send them a gift
card but
but the console install base let's be
real there's still a lot of xbox
it's cool no i'm just saying you can't
get a ser you can't get a series
anything right now right i just went to
stockx and ordered a series x i mean
series s the other day i just did it
right four hundred dollars i'm gonna pay
a hundred dollars foolish tax just to
get another one and and what i'm saying
is people don't have it already
available i think they would have cut
them off if these consoles would have
been readily available but you can't cut
off that base yeah that's already
available no i get what you say
let me get tony on that particular i got
to get his point like what do you feel
about that with all the different
variants and consoles of xbox versions
of it with halo infinite yeah i mean
i've been very vocal about this on
twitter like i'm not a fan of having
games on last year i'm like listen that
stuff is holding us back i'm talking
about even on playstation like as well
as like we got you know horizon like how
much better could it have looked if it
wasn't tied to that but here's my
question you guys because i i will admit
i'm ignorant about this right is it
isn't xcloud available on base xbox now
thank you yeah xcloud is available i
think you guys know where i'm going with
that right no eagles so i'm like okay
you promised this game to last gen
owners fine
give the game to them
through xcloud that way they get to play
a game and the game isn't compromised i
i understand they're not going to be
able to do this i understand that
because it's already been developed they
promised it but i think that's an
elegant solution to this instead of like
tethering these games to
tethering stuff not even a word no no no
ball and chaining these games
sorry for the language that i'm like
cut that off you know just focus on the
x and the s and you'll be good and the
old guy you know the guys on on on the
on the dirty xbox one you know
so yeah so you cut them off and you'll
be good you know because that i didn't
think about that angle you write it's
like yo what if this delay is happening
because they can't get the stuff
generally
bro let me tell you something this is
the crux of the knee bent you know for
uh me
against uh cog and soccer
i said long time ago
let those
the dusty xboxes let those dudes
stream it let them x cloud it right you
still get to experience it you know but
you get the x cloud
and that way you still get to hang out
with the big boys you might have a
little latency issue that's due to you
know the hallway limitations but we
still get to experience how we need to
play i feel y'all but here's the thing
but even the guy even the guys playing
the old on those systems will still
express it the way everybody's supposed
to be experiencing oh yeah everybody
wishes
like i understand that there's some
people in the country that can't get
high speed internet
i i understand that but at the same time
it's not this isn't the early start
we've gotta wait for them yeah
that they will be supporting the last
consoles after that if you look at what
xbox's lineup is it's all yeah
as a matter if you look at a lot of the
xbox streams if you look at the xbox
streams they don't say xbox one anymore
like the games are like some of the
recent streams when they show you the
platforms on it says pc xbox series x
and s
that's good we're moving in directories
because i'm one of those guys like
listen when i'm moving off to next gen i
want next-gen experiences i'm done with
the whole stuff you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah but you know but to three bits
point right three bits point when they
talked about the two-year support for
the old console right we talked about
how that was a narrative they created
for themselves and they got negative
press around it and it never and it
never materialized right yeah i feel the
same way about him calling this a live
service game
specifically in reference to the
single-player part okay because i don't
think that's true
so once again he's it feels like he
stepped on a rake saying
and again creating a narrative around
game pass that oh
game pass gets unfinished games the live
service portion of this game feels like
it's going to be the multiplayer lesson
by sony though
okay we got to move on no no no
my bad um actually the entire game is
because the game is launching with
multiple campaigns so like they're
inspired it's crazy by destiny like the
campaign that we did
that both the campaign and the
multiplayer are expected to last 10 plus
years so like we may not see what's the
the
the
the monkey everybody likes
my atrial fibrillation
so we might not see him
the the launch campaign right right
somebody else but he may be like
no season three yeah baby to take a kick
version i got you i guess yeah
but this is my thing right like i've
always my criticism of of of uh destiny
has been like
everything that's not an actual
straight-up mission right to whatever
like a story mission feels like it's
just like a hub world where there's
really nothing that feels alive right
are they going to do that to halo
like
am i going to walk around this halo and
it'd be like what the hell is this like
i'm just waiting to get to the next
story thing to actually get content that
feels alive and it feels like it's in
that world like i don't want that to be
honest
i think they want more of an ingrained
feeling which is why they they're going
for that uh that camera sort of like god
of war where they said it's like one
camera cut and
and uh
yeah when you think about like live
service with halo where where i think
what kids move is kind of getting on i'm
hoping it still feels complete like you
finish it and then
later you can get like i don't know uh
campaign part two i know battlefield did
this right yeah but that was they
released campaign after after was that
battlefield yeah i think so uh
yeah yeah they released the multiplayer
first person
you know we got to see what's going to
happen obviously we all going to play
this game when it launched you know what
i'm saying that's not the issue no one's
saying because even though i am
devastated that the campaign's not
beautiful
i am going to play it yes you know i'm
saying but at the end of the day that's
what i say is just that i hope
that this game when it comes out if
hopefully in november whatever that it
has to polish on your birthday yeah i
know of course that's why i'm definitely
connected to it
that that's when it's coming out
i just hope it is as well polished and
because god forbid if there are issues
you already know bro you're ready people
going
they can't the co-op lords are going to
be and the forge lords are going to be
like yeah this which i wanted
so
that that crowd is going to get smaller
after three months but like i said
before like i
they go out there they sing either you
ready to sing or you're not fair enough
right and that's it we don't have no
more time with this three four stuff you
guys either gotta perform or get on to
something else and we hope that their
voice is ready when it's time i love
them i think
they better not be cracking they better
hear every note otherwise the sandman
lords are coming with the hook and they
get them off the stage and that's that
so please get the super chats we gotta
go yeah we have a considerable we're
about to get it let's go we gotta get it
we gotta get something at least so you
wanna wait to the end because it's a lot
bro there there are a lot
i need to scroll back just pay attention
to the last stuff
um because it's that yeah i got the last
stuff up yeah then we catch up because
we got it we can't disrespect them they
out here yeah yeah
they're outside for this one okay okay
okay hold on a second to the panel if
you want to if anyone has to go i know
we're going crazy long it's cool yeah i
know we're going wrong yeah i'll
probably have to dip around four if
that's all right no yeah don't doubt
that
we get you with that ghost then we can
get you up all right no doubt
okay
uh okay we got solar panels
we have nam omar up i guess he's going
into lord silva let's put the crest in
the chat for now omar absolutely what's
up then we got the medic 10 super chat
if you play single player only
multiplayer only or not playing these
game modes and you're complaining about
halo you capping
halo is still going to have more
features than most other games out there
stop capping hashtag fake concerns wow
forget your co-op
there we got the medic uh upgrading his
membership to lord silva
salute that's himself then we got kiss
move five dollar super chat call attic
when the halo news broke and i can hear
the disappointment in his voice
yeah it was real
there we got brett bingham five dollar
super chat everyone needs to stop
talking about halo infinite not
launching with co-op like the people who
won't stop talking during cut scenes
when playing co-op thank you
here we go
there we go
with the 10 super chat for me xbox is
halo and halo is co-op
xbox has always been great for co-op the
precedent here is bad co-op isn't a
feature it is halo definitely reduces
the hype for me
and we got hargie cheney again with the
five dollar super chat also who believes
it will be a three month delay for co-op
why is a coalition can deliver without
excuses but 343 can't
smoke
the devil
shame the devil that's a lot of smoke
then a big shout out to gerald mack for
upgrading the membership to lord silva
put the crush in the chat for john hello
always wrapping the lords oh wait
absolutely
then we got victor alestine five dollars
which had any thoughts on the disney
buying sony movie studios to get
spider-man rumors support great guests
i hope that happens i hope disney buys
them in its entirety
and sells them to marcus
thank you for watching
super chat i'm in the other boat trying
to shoot y'all down give me halo now no
doubt
you don't even wait for november he
wants it right now
[ __ ] with the five dollars in the chat
i have a question why people are
screaming about this when the last of us
part two kept the multiplayer out of the
game and we're still waiting for it well
no they're gonna sell you that uh with
the haptic feedback and the 3d audio
chris hart is like a high sense tv with
a tcl remote and a broken westinghouse
soundbar he just doesn't make sense
though
i gotta stop beefing in the chat
right i gotta calm down bro it ain't
that serious
so we got jd gamer 10 super chat i gotta
do it i find myself pissed but not
because microsoft delayed a couple of
features it's because of the messaging
and marketing around
news dropped on a friday so we knew
yeah good news does not drop on a friday
you know
that we have lord roughness five pounds
super chat no more broken co-ops
outriders dark alliance the ascent
but absolutely all right no more delays
launched halo infinite this fall
he said he said yo all that broken stuff
no more don't do it no no no
that's the point halo there people want
that halo they don't care continue
that's my point
then we have edwin suero two dollars
watch the co-op be spartan ops to make
story sense
then we have neil wise 10 super chat
multiplayer is a live service can
release in beta and nobody cares
campaign is not and paying for game pass
for 60 dollars and it's not future
feature complete and has no hardware
features is not acceptable
that is true let me get i'll help you
out alvin find out super chat early
rumors of a consistent camera that never
leaves chief in campaign ala god of war
could this be causing issues with co-op
since single player is ready yep me and
three bit talked about the rumor you're
gonna get expert
merc
yeah e-league jake
said about the camera again
he got incontinence issues like expert
we got an ex burger 10 super chat
when i compare being excited for a game
to launch in 1999 to today
it quickly becomes clear that we may be
expecting too much yes 343 should have
done better but come on it's still going
to be awesome do we do this
i believe so yeah that's that's what we
hope
my hope my hope is with them with all
this time that they do produce us it's a
stellar game
i give them the benefit of yeah
yeah paris has been saying this the
longest time he's like it can't just be
okay
yeah we got dan lazaro five dollars in
the chat less than ten percent of
players use co-op and forge i don't know
uh we need these numbers i want to see
those numbers halo is a business and
they cannot miss another holiday or
anniversary those modes are glorified
add-ons
they should have dropped news on a
monday while telling us they have
something special in store for us that
they're excited to show us what the
extra dev time has allowed them to
accomplish oh i guess it continues
somewhere yeah so i see it's continued
chat um even with the covid uh had
forced them to delay a couple features
but those features are going to be great
and we can't wait for you to play it
okay that's what he's saying he thinks
they're gonna say whatever okay well i
hope so again i hope uh drunken ninja
five dollars which at the people have
been waiting for a good halo game and
that's it if the story is amazing and
the multiplayer is fun then it's fine
i agree
um okay already clutch clutch man are
you out here yeah delayed fight out
super chat delay co-op and fortune
halo's the least of all worries ps5 has
yet to provide an experi
an expansion ssd back by warranty what
are we doing
it's out there and you know it's in beta
so absolutely clutch man be a messy bit
then we got lord roughness five pound
super chat any more delays for halo
infinite and i might lose interest shout
out to cyberpunk 2077 i'm no longer
waiting for cdpr update after 10 plus
months i am [ __ ] j 5 super chat i'm
not usually willing to call for
somebody's job but
bonnie ross what the hell did she have
the team doing for six years it's not
ready but i'm still playing okay i think
it i think it's way more than just
bonnie ross situation i mean you we
don't know internationally we don't know
a lot more we don't have switching from
one engine to the next engine
you know um this culvert stuff yeah
now for the question what were they
playing to release lassie if the game
isn't complete
and
yeah that to me yeah what's scary is
that they even had an inkling about
releasing this game last year
i think it would have been lit
time
move it over
shafiq baxter
speaking facts 343 is damned if they
don't and damn if they do yeah no doubt
rated blade five pounds with your hello
lords i don't care about the co-op of
forge multiplayer game campaign is where
i'm at cool right uh flame 5 super chat
sob you don't want to kill craig's
extended family with the realm on
legendary man we got a whole ring this
time gotta get lonely lonely
dps podcast what up 10 super chat just
want to remind everyone that gearbox did
four player co-op on open maps with
borderline brother lance two nine years
ago no excuse for not having features
that have always been available after
last year's delay okay slo-mo the human
encyclopedia remembers everything oh
yeah yeah yeah
sounds slow
rate and blade five pounds super chat
co-op and forced to follow three months
later is not a problem so why the heat
at least they're informing us all right
jd gamer 10 super chat all three four
three all bonnie ross has to do is
deliver an outstanding halo game that
shuts everyone up yes until they do that
they need to stop with the
self-inflicted wounds poor man there we
go i want a great stepping on the rake
stop stepping on the rig please uh
michael askew junior 20 super chat sorry
i'm late lord chilling with the kids
doing that darn beta update today for my
ssd wish me luck beta boys salute raiden
blade two pounds super chat attic you're
right last of us two still missing
factions okay then we have strong sick
knicks fan five dollar super chat
i love bonnie but it might be time for
phil to make some changes at 343 he's
letting them turn xbox's billion dollar
ip into a piecemeal xbox live arcade
game wow i'm gonna tell you right now i
don't know
an award this year for this game
all of this is calling for her reaching
for her grabbing for it's going to be a
lot of stuff in that crow back in that
box so i'm going to refrain
today deliver first before i just come
for a head no no i want to see her on
that stage getting an award for
all this you know hate mail that she's
probably receiving from these fans that
was toxic you just read soft
yeah toxic knicks fan there we go yeah
michael okay so there you go story uh
chat the story co-op and forage was
never mentioned by media outlets or make
as make a break previously this is silly
og xbox halo player i'm over this lander
all right scoob we got you there we have
rdx son of fete with the 2.79
super chat they're going to add the
campaign over time all right this is a
big one optimus code 50 super chat i
heard you and you made some sense no
doubt while i do admit you have an
excellent point i was surprised you took
it as seriously as you did many vids
have been made about me i thought it was
just funny if you legit offended we
could talk about it all right first for
the record we never made a video about
you second yes as men you guys should
talk behind the scenes and no one should
be making videos about each other
exactly and that's what we should do
not from us not from us not from us but
as men let's get behind the scenes and
work that out and just enhance things
out correct
uh rate and blade 10-pound super chat
what's the proof that halo's a buggy
mess did this developer work on the
project two years ago or less
why aren't you putting your name out
there because you want to keep your job
yeah that's probably why
when we go find out who leaky jake is
and you gone buddy
snitches and stitches
gamer o'malley two dollars two pound
super chat what are those uh what about
those who co-op every halo stop the cap
it's true
raiden blade for me two pound [ __ ] but
cog it's still coming it's not like it's
not yeah it's it's still coming but like
i said we can't have it yeah we want a
future full game that was delayed that's
all good
urban ninja five dollar super chat
pretty sure this game will get story
content for the next 10 years
raiden blade five pounds super chat cog
why isn't battlefield 2042 campaign not
launching multiplayer why are we doing
what about ism let's talk about
the issue right here just don't do that
yeah let's not do that salute do you
rate them later yeah we got slow-mo 2.00
those who don't want to delay really
shout out to brat father super chat take
him to church tony go and get you back
on brat new york piece of greater the
chicago piece
oh by the way i probably should be
saying that's a new yorker
obviously our pizza is the best but
chicago style it's pretty good
i don't know
yeah it's good um it's not pizza it's
like
it's not pizza it's good
super chat halo infinite the mass effect
andromeda
oh my god savage listen three for three
i will say like like
the worst halo is is an amazing game
you know and i think people need to like
think about that like yes three four
three
um they make some questionable decisions
sometimes and some of their promises
they always keep especially with the mcc
but their
games are still amazing they're still
really good games so i i think people
should you know clarify that
for sure
captain chat's five pound super chat if
the halo campaign is a live service like
destiny then that changes everything in
the game should be delayed
i just don't think it's that man
don't yo do me a favor solve i'll get
the next one but brett bringham said we
missed one i'll get the next one if you
could look some breadbreaker said we
missed one horace 5 super chat no wood
rubbing in halo let's not get bad
practices started before the tea bagging
of clowns start your favorite game mode
is not going to save your lack of skill
all right i'll keep going look for the
other one
did you find brett no i would say brett
just put it in the regular chat and i'll
just read it from there yeah rubber knob
i don't know if it's australian download
switch the whole studio is working from
home this creates all kinds of problems
just as jason ronald said on your show
it's a miracle anyone is releasing
anything yeah that's cool just take your
time ain't no need to run um ultra msv 5
superchat first time catching the show
live thank you for the entertainment as
i grind through this max payne 3
multiplayer trophy salute urban ninja
313 follow super chat borderlands co-op
still tethered all four players to each
other not to mention its open world
still had loading zones not the same he
mad at slo-mo caitlyn fought out of
superchat no more delays been waiting
too long to teabag three bit
three [ __ ] she coming for you what's
this hey hey we have a rivalry going on
okay okay
and then she laughing let's go faster
rally gaming find out some chat statin
statement a live service game is never
really complete end quote i am skeptical
of this direction also if the game is
incomplete it should launch in my
opinion dead planet follow the super
chat the worst part of halo infinite is
it exemplifies how dire xbox first party
situation is expensive 2017 they had
nothing in the chamber okay shots fired
rain and blade 2000 super chat hate [ __ ]
much love bro you're right always love
brother you already know d skills h town
follow super chat remember 343 went
through a management change in the
middle of this i am sure it disrupted
everything a lot of some validity yeah
rubbing okay rubber knob and go to get
that one solve it and be done yeah the
rubber knob
five dollars
how funny would it be to if your mate on
co-op is correct and last one before
brett bring him i got you halo 5 never
had split screen and everyone is
complaining about a three-month delay
for co-op needs to grow up damn
damn thank you bro
all right look we got to get this off
because i got to get my man tony on this
and this is a topic that i'm very
important goes to
it is out my man tony has an amazing
review up right now on pcmag.com
4.5 excellent review sir so let's talk
about it you're feeling about the game
so far and then also on side point i
know it's not the same game but there's
a little controversy
skyrim um i believe a special
anniversary edition
and people are upset because they're
saying that you know why were people
upset about uh director's cut from
goshishima getting a lot of vitriol when
they feel that this is a similar
situation so first the game itself
iki island i didn't get a chance to
touch yet i told you about my issues
offline but um that and then the old
skyrim thing
yeah so this was a cool review for me
because i actually never reviewed the
original game i think somebody else on
the team handled it right um so
this was my favorite game of last year i
said that many times uh the last of us
fans too don't like when i say that by
the way they got all me man
yeah yeah but i've said this from the
jump i'm like yo listen that 30 dollars
man i think it was worth it that content
and after playing it was like 20 hours
worth of content i feel is great like
and it's dope because like the main game
had this really like great story arc for
gin that was complete there was only one
thing that was a little bit of a loose
end right yeah and you get the you
finally get to see that through i'm like
oh so we get another character art for
gin you know you get to see a different
aspect of them but but it's just so well
done but at the end of the day it is
still more of the same which i'm not
complaining about you get the same you
know presentation the combat and
everything although it took me like a
good hour to get back in trouble i'm
rusty as hell right now bro i'm getting
jacked up once i got once i got back
into i'm like you know it's so good um i
like some of the new mechanics that have
you some new techniques uh your horse
now like not only can you arm it up or
you can have it ram into you
which is really dope
you know um it's just a lot of fun it
was just so cool getting back in like we
talked about before uh the show started
like it's weird it's like yeah if this
game where like all this heavy stuff is
happening um japan's being invaded
you're killing a bunch of dudes but
there's also serene too and like you
said like the world itself is a
character you know it's like you every
inch of it just drips with like like
such nuance i could tell the developer
just went so and i love that about this
game like you could tell they really
appreciate japan they love the culture
and i just came through so much that
even the you know japanese don't really
like western games so much they love
this game and they're like oh thank you
for respecting us in this vein you know
so that that love really comes through
and i guess the only kind of criticism i
would have about this game this is a
weird one um graphically it wasn't as
upgraded as it like you would think it
would be because it had already been
upgraded previously on ps4 with that
free upgrade you know so i'm out like
obviously the textures do look a little
bit better but like
like it would have been kind of more fun
if we didn't get that upgrade at all
initially and then we got it with this
one because
yeah yeah
[Music]
you know and that but because i will say
this when i played the original one on
regular 1080p tv right so playing this
joint on a 4k
hdr you know i'm like whoa this is
something else man so this game you know
i think it is worth it yes it is a
last-gen game technically but there's
not a lot on playstation right now let's
just be honest so definitely worth
picking this up like i understand why
some people would be upset over the
pricing but to me
it was it's definitely worth it i was
ready to just buy this on my own until
sony you know blessed me with the code
but i was ready for it i was like yo
let's go because i want to say i may
still buy just because again i want to
support this thing you know it is great
i love full disclosure because a lot of
times you know people don't get full
disclosure
when it comes to things because um
when when you get something and you
don't have to come out of pocket there's
there's no remorse for that aspect of a
pay because you said six hours for 30
bucks plus whatever bells and whistles
that they did put on it i think six
hours 30 bucks that equates to a good
price point right yeah and then the
upgrades that they did give you two of
the story that you already established
and you're endeared to and it enriches
the story so i think that 30 bucks six
hours i think that's definitely in that
price range now if somebody's purchasing
the game from the beginning all the way
through i don't know what the price
total is it's 60 60 for ps4 and 70 for
ps5 well i'm talking about well play
play playstation 5. you know like you're
going for the playstation 5 and then you
get the extra ikky island
that's 100 purchase you know going in uh
for the game
and i believe the game is worth that
because like you said the crafting that
they did do with the game the feelings
that they do give to the game and to
hear somebody say that they jumped out
and they were a little bit rusty and
they had to go back into it but you
still you know toughed it out because
the story was so rich and it was so
nuanced i i always felt that it was
like um assassin's creed light
type of like open world light type of
thing because it led you and the world
is breathing because the wind and the
gust and the stuff like that and it
always attracts your eyes and different
things so like hearing you talk about it
and and these guys have a different
appreciation for the game than i do uh
but every time i hear somebody talk
about the game it's the artistic
uh giving that they gave to everybody
else and
the love is shown and i i love the fact
that they keep going back to the world
giving back to the fans yeah yeah for
sure think about the multiplayer like
they dropped that multiplayer like oh
here's multiplayer for free nobody
expected that here you go and that
legends mode is fire it's very it is yes
now the quick question on the
controversy obviously we knew about the
director's cut we knew about the extra
thing we added lip sync they added the
extra features there was some
controversy for some people right now
obviously there's a new edition i
believe um was it skyrim coming back
again you don't say it yeah anniversary
edition three dlcs dawn guard heart fire
whatever so it looks like there's going
to be an added component this creation
club that's gonna be um i don't know if
you read any of this stuff so my
question is do you think the criticism
is valid for people who say where's the
energy for people that was coming at go
suzushima for paying for that upgrade as
opposed to this one with this skyrim
anniversary edition yeah it's a weird
inconsistency like i didn't know too
much about this but like okay so this
game gets like paid add-on stuff you get
mad about it this other game that's been
out for like three generations now it it
gets for you know a paid ad on but it's
okay how does that work i don't i don't
really understand so to me it just seems
like actually this is just conjecture
right now i think i think a lot of this
is coming from you know fanboy stuff
like they just want to dunk on ghost
sushima because skyrim is on everything
there's there's no fanboyism going on
there so i could be wrong about this
it's just me conjecture right now that's
what it seems like a lot of people are
just complaining because a lot of
complaints at least from what i see on
twitter are not coming from placing guys
some are mad but it's mostly from like
crazy xbox and i make this by the way i
do want to make a distinction is there a
difference between xbox fans and xbox
fanboys xbox fans are i was about to
curse xbox fans are awesome xbox fans
are effing awesome right xbox fans are
but xbox fanboys and sony fanboys not we
don't need to deal with that so i think
it's just people trying to just justify
just like you know the same sony guys
are dunking on halo because of the
omission of co-op you know it's like all
right you guys would just use any little
thing for everybody
yeah i i don't pay attention to that
stuff man you know i yeah not for you
about three bit you want to get it yeah
yeah i was just saying i don't think
it's the same thing like the skyrim
updates you're getting for free right
right it's the dlc
and if you look at game pass a lot of
dlc games like you think of forza you
still have to pay for right the dlc for
the yeah but if you wanted those
upgrades those are free
um there is not you know there's no
paywall or anything like that a lot of
people saying no they saying it
they know
they're like where's that keep that same
energy three bit that's what they said
i know people are saying that but to me
i don't think it's the same thing like
you
it's
the whole upgrade thing like if you if
you want to be able to experience your
game a better fidelity and think i'm
always in the camp where i think those
should be free okay um but
uh dlc and stuff like that i understand
this based on what's in game pass right
now the dlc for most games are
yeah you have to pay for the paper yeah
i'm not fair enough enough to go quickly
oh kids move i don't know if you um been
paying attention to the whole skyrim
stuff you mute it sir i just want to
make sure that you're good um yeah like
what what's your feeling on that the
director's cut if he did play but if not
the whole controversy between this and
um skyrim anniversary
um
the thing to my knowledge right the
the actual
anniversary edition the actual package
itself won't be in game pass right the
um
yeah from my understanding they said i
think they're gonna present
okay
i know you get the upgrade the like yes
the upgrade example yeah so for example
we have the remaster right right
we the p there's a ps5 in series x
version so we will get that
the proper next conversion yes the extra
additional content that below creation
club right yeah yeah we don't get that
correct right now this was similar to
this is all i was asking for goes to
tsushima
so this is not like um
like a two-face thing or i'm like not
giving the same energy all i wanted for
because i owned ghost tsushima right
right i do not own the director's cut i
was like not it's the same reason why i
don't own the ultimate edition of
control i own the original game i was
like
like
out give me the upgrades i bought the
game day one of each of these games day
one all right if you're gonna if i have
these games in my library you can
validate it give me the upgrades
to counter to conte in fairness the icky
island part is new story content that's
fine okay so are you willing are you
willing to pay for the iggy island which
is
okay man i don't mind buying expansions
in dlc got you okay
the ghost of tsushima in order for me to
get the full ps5 support minus ikki
island i have to buy iki island right so
i have to buy the game again or one
it wasn't the resolution of just null
and void it was just like the same
resolution no so what they did is
so
so for example the version of ghost of
the shima i have which is the ps4 pro
version uh to run at an unlock uh frame
rate right is you get the same ps4 pro
resolution which was like a checkerboard
1800p it was like 1440 right
1800 p like final now the proper ps5
version gets a
checkerboard 4k so it's uh it's okay so
it goes up yeah yeah
you get this you get a slight upgrade on
the videos but you get the dawson
support you get the japanese support and
whatnot the lip sync the lipstick
because and then i found out what the
lip sync was about i found out that
before that was full motion video and
that wasn't actual cut scenes made
generated by hardware yeah that's right
now it's uh it's generated by the
hardware so i can understand why the lip
sync thing was a issue yeah uh and it
was because of the ssd type of situation
it was running too fast for the full
motion video and all this other stuff
and once that stuff is explained later
i don't really think they really had to
talk about the lip sync thing because it
became a end of a joke it became a butt
of a joke yeah like you're paying
yesterday you know an addict contributed
to it
you know of course
it's a level of ignorance when it comes
to a situation that we can find jokes at
and it's all done in good fun
but again
you know like like the kid uh smooth's
point
paying for dlc
is admirable and it's okay i do it all
the time for the destiny i keep that
same energy for that dlc you get the dlc
it's extra content that the developer
worked on that's great but to his point
where he's talking about he has the
playstation 4 uh
purchase right and he has a playstation
5. you can look in my system and tell
that i purchased this game can i get
these upgrades to take advantage of this
you really can't
because there's two different codes that
goes into this game and it's just
because of that lip sync thing that
everybody is not really you know we're
making jokes at it right it's a real
large aspect of it because it's a very
cinematic game yeah
now when you take that aspect out
and you made it part of the game you
made those full motion not for motion no
more it's actual in-game graphics cut
scenes
now that's really an upgrade right so
it should be paid for no doubt no doubt
oh kid did you finish it it's just hard
to get prepared
so far um it's just hard to compare
like when i think about that i just
think about what xbox says so like
lately with how they offer everything
kind of for free right away with a lot
of their upgrades like hellblade and
that's what happens when you're losing
i mean
that's true
i mean
when you lose it you do a whole lot of
things when you lose yeah you got it
you're right you're doing it right you
have to be right after about that time
you messed up with your girl you opened
the door last generation yeah we know
what happened like you think the thing
is so
because skyrim is the same situation but
like so skyrim they get you're getting
the upgrades for the proper system but
there you know obviously you have to buy
you actually you essentially if you want
the full experience of the university
you have to um buy which is which is
fine you know what i mean um
but
my only thing about it with skyrim is
that
unless i'm reading it wrong i'm just a
little put off that the entire that that
package won't be in game
so you're
winning game pass
yeah like because you're now like it's
it's an ex i mean it's an xbox product
at this point right right
and it's like it somewhat goes against
you know the promise of the of the first
party so that's the only thing i have um
i think that game was in development
before
three pick you was going to finish
saying something before i passed it so
and reference to that or in reference to
these the skyrim thing
oh we're gonna get tony i don't know
no i mean yeah i listen when it comes to
the ghost of sweden like i said at the
start of the show i i just finished the
main campaign
um so the own i haven't played ikey
island i haven't played any new stuff
that tony was talking about so i am
excited to play that next week
um
now when it comes to comparing the two
versions the same thing i had i had my
ps4 version upgraded on my ps5 right and
i had a ps5 version so i went back and
forth to see
and yeah when it it's just
frame rate got got rectified with that
pro version right so it really just was
a resolution bump so i guess
i have the same issue with i don't have
an issue paying twenty dollars for extra
content that's great the ten dollars for
the upgrade that we got
doesn't necessarily feel justified so
yeah beyond that whatever i paid the tax
i did it because i just want that i want
that one version and that's it yeah but
yeah it there really wasn't a lot there
if we had gotten ray tracing and stuff
like that whatever
that and maybe that's something that
comes later who knows wait there's no
rage racing no no
stop it
we need ray tracing on the grass
get that that aspect
is
disappointing now you care about ray
chase if it goes no i really care about
rachel oh now you're doing right now
yeah i thought i thought with the lip
sync
i thought
so all right so oh that's going to come
with the next dlc
who knows man
listen
they they set you up nice and good they
gave you the first one for free they say
that multiplayer bloody
yes of course that sounds
[Laughter]
you crazy remember we gave you that
crazy multiplayer he wasn't looking for
that it's like true that true that let
me get that
that's not how it went
that's how it was the king king works
for sony
[Music]
yeah
and then on the skyrim thing yeah i kind
of agree with kid like it's
on the surface it's not a big deal at
all right we we get certain upgrades
we're going to get like console-wise
upgrades but not content upgrades that
the anniversary edition is getting um as
opposed to a special edition i do agree
with kid though like
you've made this you set this precedent
where everything is in game pass and now
you know
not quite not quite so it's just again
i don't want to make a big deal out of
it but if if it begins to set a a kind
of wishy-washy middle ground sort of
precedent then we got to start watching
that sort of stuff no doubt look i'll
finish up um ghosts looks amazing i was
just in my feelings i totally but one
thing i i it i will take blame it was a
cognito issue you know what i'm saying
okay which is you know when i started
the joint and it had the transfer from
ps4 right yeah so i already knew my save
data from ps4 to ps5 was a wrap because
i thought ps plus automatically cloud
saved like xbox do and i didn't have to
do any manual push to tell my ps plus
excuse me what happens when we assume
shut up
so i lost all my data it was a i knew
that was coming in right it hurt but i
know but here's the double hurt that i
was in my feelings that's why they
played this league was that when i did
the transfer right it said do you want
to transfer and it had my ps4 back
compat version of of go sushima there
which i started earlier this year
because i started over all right i got
to start over i'm on act one whatever
it transfers over so i'm starting to
play the game
and i guess you know let's say i'm
starting ready getting ready to start
act two
and then and achieve a bronze popped up
and i'm like wait a minute i platinum
this game why is the old
platinums coming out of old uh trophies
coming up and i'm like
they stole my trophies no i'm freaking
out i'm like oh no doesn't this sound
like confessions of a playstation fan
shut up
so i had to check myself i went and i
looked through the trophy list so what
has happened is
they have allowed the import my ps4
trophies did not go
i found they basically treat it as two
ghost toshibas so it's a ps4 my ps4 one
still has this platinum okay you know i
was like oh okay oh god oh my god cause
i was in my i was like it's bad enough
the date it was gone don't you take my
platinum
hat
just real quick i do gotta add this in
there because i i already i was i didn't
know that was gonna happen right um but
as soon as i started i'm like oh this is
just like jedi falling order in
spiderman it's just popping so i'm like
bam bam bam bam trophies are coming but
but i didn't get my platinum like what
is going on where's my platinum i know i
got a platinum so i started playing iki
island as soon as i got a trophy within
iki island and then the pawn popped up
so so i was like dope i went from 81 81
applied them to 82. you know
so at least i get a chance at a second
so i would have started that i got out
of my feelings i'm going to start as far
as the um skyrim thing i mean i don't
really care i'm going to speak to matty
on the fine duke but he's the skyrim
dude i got to get the details on it but
you know as far as the content creation
part that does feel like separate dlc
that feels like some uh community driven
thing it's partially community it's
partially but does it themselves so it's
some of it is like smaller just content
from bethesda so it's i mean it's it's a
cool thing and plus it has all the dlc
and all that stuff yes i believe the the
uh which people call it the special
edition has yeah well
um yeah so it's just that it's just that
it's it's the most feature complete
version version of the thing yeah look i
get it if some people feel it until the
next one until the next one yeah we got
to get tony out here this man has stood
for the marathon oh my god lord tony
polanco game journalist og vet queens in
the building and throw down show
representative mommy
where can i find people find you what
else you got going on sir all right
before that i want to thank you guys
again for having me on you know what i'm
saying i love what you guys have going
here making us look good i love the the
passion the professionalism i love the
face shout out to all the fans who've
been chilling with us the whole time you
know uh throwing money at you like
because i i feel like that stuff helps
you know it keeps us doing what we're
doing so appreciate the whole community
is great and yeah if you want to find me
i'm over on twitter at romneydeath
that's r-o-m-u-d-e-t-h
and in my bar you're gonna see links to
every place i write for i write for
pcmag laptop mag and i am the host of
the throwdown show which airs every
single thursday and sunday night at 10
30 p.m eastern thursday it's a show much
like this one where we discuss all the
big gaming news and sunday is when we
answer the fan questions that show is
always crazy and popping and i already
know during this show i was looking at
my discord where all the fans were going
crazy leaving a question i'm like we got
a lot of halo questions tonight so this
may be i then maybe my my second third
hour podcast
it's the life bro
but yeah man you know find me on twitter
and uh keep the conversation but keep it
civil because i will block you yeah guys
you know what i'm saying but yeah i
gotta get going fellas thanks for having
me on and i will hopefully be on bro
we're bringing you back you already know
bro thank you so much for your time man
so much love you dropped so many jewels
got so much respect and we got to
support each other and i love what you
represent and i'm sorry it took so long
to get you you know all right we're good
we're we're going to be doing more you
want to say yeah i'll chose tony before
we leave everybody real quick so new
york pizza stand up yeah
good seeing you man absolutely man you
know me i i love having my we got the
eminem boys baby mongoose
baby
baby break up these boys
it's a beautiful thing though man like
really like
it's the same way you say that we we we
do our best to try to make you know our
people look good you've been doing it
for a long time brother really
appreciate it thank you brother enjoy
your day man please all right guys take
care of that
super chat so we good last one
we have let me see let me roll back a
little bit i think we're good we got uh
no hold on
wrap where pc doesn't have this issue
well from what i hear with pc y'all
about to be shut down because they're
about to cut off those gaming rigs it's
over why they cut off the game oh okay
so different states is having different
laws against pc gaming rigs talking
about their uh going against um
the the environment something like that
it already started in california
and um they're trying to push those
legislations all across america uh and
and it's a real thing so all you pc
master race dudes live it up right now
because it's about to be over ridiculous
what else you saw you showed up i
thought we did we missed a couple i see
his food yeah we gotta put the crust in
the chat for alex escort
yes then we got uh raiden blade five
pound super chat hey chris hart sony
don't talk so how can you make a
statement on their behalf unless you
work for them
christopher i get that smoke everywhere
today then we got michael aka best stars
finest five dollar super chat where is
the energy for grand theft auto that's
been out for three generations the
people want to cry but skyrim about
skyrim amazing god bless a less amount
i think we missed the homie one bad
mother did we get him no you read that
one that was about the wood rubbing no
another one bad mother he said not much
to add that hasn't been said oh it has
been said today yes right other than
that yeah other than for others to take
a look and see how to disagree and
discuss respectfully yeah that's rubbing
before did you get the rubbing out
before that one because that was not the
only one i think we missed yes no
i think we read that wrong okay cool
just want to make sure okay cool yeah
i'm sorry it was horus that said the no
wood rubbing yes
out of control
um yeah we're caught up with that's when
you're not from new york you don't know
about the popularity oh uh uh best-sized
finest like i said i don't know if you
saw it in the chat get at me on twitter
please i owe you a gift card so please i
can't find you otherwise no doubt final
time will be quick for anyone who has
played there's a game out right there so
this game is coming out very polarizing
it seems quite quite polarizing yeah i
guess so what's going on what's this
game
so uh 12 minutes is a game by uh by luis
antonia
um
it is published by annapurna it's a game
that we here at ireland's podcast have
seen now for the past three years since
2017-2018 shout out to patrick maca for
for after we saw it
yeah we saw this at the xbox showcase uh
e3 2018 i believe it was and then we
spoke to patrick maca who had actually
gotten the chance to see it in person i
don't know i remember if he played it or
not he was very excited about the
prospects of this game because it was
this infinite time loop uh so the story
of this game is basically that uh
there's a couple
uh and the story takes place in their
apartment and the uh the husband in in
the relationship
he is in an infinite time loop where he
goes into the apartment
things happen and
um things transpire and every time you
play a different loop it you basically
take the information you learned from
the previous loop um and try to figure
out try to move the story forward right
by manipulating things in the
environment um so in in that respect the
manipulation of the environment is very
much like old school adventure games
it's a point-and-click type of thing
where you take the things that you can
manipulate in the environment you try to
put them together in order to again
progress the story and and make things
happen in this world
um
so far i'm enjoying it the things that
the criticisms that i have about it is
that
despite the caliber of the actors in the
game i think the overall voice acting
i.e the script overall isn't super great
okay so it almost feels like it was
overkill to have these type of actors in
there
so far anyway um i haven't finished the
game yet um but
and again
the uh whatchamacallit the uh
the adventure game aspect of it is very
old school if you're not used to that
type of game
it might be very frustrating because
again if you're not a dude that played
like day of the tentacle back in the day
or whatever grim fandango that type of
stuff
it it it is it can be cumbersome because
you're like all right i gotta do this
again and again again and again um what
it does differently that than those
games right because anybody who's played
those older games knows that if you miss
an item
early on in the game that you're going
to need for later
you're kind of done yeah yeah
it it you can't like it's there's no way
of going back right it's all it's
old-school game design that had its
flaws
in this because the setting is just a
small apartment
everything is always there and the time
loop ensures that everything that you
need to to get the answers that you that
you're looking for is always there so in
that regard it kind of improves upon
that that old school sort of
development trope for this type of games
um i'm enjoying it the story is starting
to unfold in a really
bugged out way
um
and so i'm liking it i thought i was
really i was going to love it and adore
it and i'm not quite there with it yet
but i i am liking what the game is
showing me so far no doubt kids move did
you get a chance to play
absolutely let's get it what you're
feeling on it's spoiler free as possible
yeah that's that's the heart it's hard
cause that's what really opens it up
um
when i first started the game i was like
i into this loop crap because i got sick
wow disrespectful
i got sick of like that like get like
bro i'll tell you this right because
all right
when the game starts you try to do
things like on the third try i tried to
stab the dude when he was arrested
he turned around so quick and left
hooked me yeah i'm like all right all
right well but
after like just relaxing and i had to
literally think about it because one of
my favorite movies is what groundhog day
you love that you're gonna love them
yeah i'm like okay i can really figure
this out i'm like come on i'm not stupid
right and so that went back and actually
focused on it i'm like
okay
you gotta mean so
as things open up even like just small
things things on the wall in the
refrigerator right stuff like that and
i'm like
okay
so i started getting all into it and now
i'm at a point where i got like games
like this you get multiple endings to
the point where i already restarted my
playthrough now because i want to play a
particular way right
and and and unlock it because i think um
it it opens up a lot now i'm not a fan
of what it all comes to because i think
it's just
sick
and that's the thing is just like oh
like you guys could come up with a
different oh okay
wherever it goes yeah yeah he's not
about that story yeah it just goes weird
but i ain't gonna lie dude like like
when you and i understand like when i
was thinking that i wasn't studying the
game as long as you guys obviously you
guys had like you know access to the
game and stuff when it was like first
announced and stuff like that so what
i'm thinking i'm thinking this is gonna
be like another
independent you know well the camera
angle is different all right i'm gonna
the control is gonna be different it's
gonna be a just a regular independent
game i didn't think it was like a sort
of
pseudo
point click it's not right right right
right and that threw me off yes yes okay
this is going to get some taken used to
is it right is it better to drive
playing on console or if it better play
pc right sure yeah so
guy you had to get used to that
um
and then
the the other part of it was um i lost
my train of thought
was uh
oh man you're good you're hungry
my grandmother
my grandmother
get your thoughts in the middle
what do you think about what you think
about the the voice acting and the voice
that the voice acting is is great right
and i'm with you because you mentioned
something like all right
maybe it was it overkill because they
got great void actors right but all
that's there it seems like all right
this is i guess too little for these
people right yeah i mean like and no
matter how much even when you open the
dialogue and get really deep into the
story side unless still they could have
done more with these people like if
you're gonna have this you could have
just used the studio team to do to
really kind of yeah you think about it
like like james mcavoy's voice right
he sounds like he did in and wanted like
like that he's a marriage quote unquote
his american voice right it was like i
was like okay you know and and then
william the folsom's will it like
william before like
it just it didn't it didn't feel like
the script was was was meaty enough for
us right so to really like you know to
really warrant these types of actors
doing it right nothing they got the
budget but the budget went there clearly
yeah but oh real quick if you can't
finish i want to get three bits uh
opinion on the 12 uh minutes if you did
play
yeah yeah i beat it oh nice okay okay
it's really really interesting like
other people's points on it yeah i think
um
like the whole point and click thing
definitely threw me for a loop
get it
we got you bro
when i first played it um
but i enjoyed it i thought uh the
same thing with kids move the ending i
don't know
[Music]
okay okay it's interesting um but
basically the fun of it
of uh
what saab was kind of saying is it's
like when you're figuring out
how things sort of line up and since
it's groundhog day you're like okay let
me grab this let me grab this before
this clock strikes to this time and
when you're like figuring that stuff out
that stuff is pretty fun to me yeah um
the voice acting
it's like hit or miss sometimes i'm like
oh he did a really good job and other
times i'm like why did he say this yeah
yeah yeah great i agree it's like
sometimes it goes up and down but i love
the concept because i don't think i've
played a game yeah that is groundhog day
you know um so i really enjoyed the
concept of it it was really different um
and i sort of needed to play a game like
this i've been playing too many shooters
and
explosions
type so it was really nice to just like
uh just relax and go through the motions
of the story and and i i really enjoyed
no doubt no doubt king i don't know if
you got a chance to play yet or heard
about it yeah i played 12 minutes or 12
minutes
so um
because i was listening to the dudes in
the chat we was talking about and just
like yo yo yo you gotta play you gotta
play man yo yo you gotta get into it man
it's the parts that you're gonna like
man
the cosby shoves me and i'm like what
like
like i'm trying to tell people don't
tell me about it right oh i want to
experience but um it's like one aspect
that i heard about it and i want to get
to that part of the game
so
i i want to see it um i know sovereign
has been very high on this game
from the inception of the said game so
um
i hope it lives up to his thing but uh
simon has been on a roll with his picks
for me so
um i i
remember when i tell you guys look to
somebody that you uh they know you your
style yeah they you know you respect a
uh review opinion of things and
they taste kind of aligned with jesse so
um every pick that sovereign has had
you know for me has always been spot on
so he's like really my defunct go-to
when i'm looking for a new title that i
don't know too much about like uh
whether my cousin pedro
uh
oh yeah my friend pedro yeah yeah
there's a lot of stuff that um
we share the same thoughts when it comes
to games so he's really high on this and
i'm going to you know dive deep i
thought i was going to get a chance to
do it yesterday but we spent three hours
on yeah
yeah yeah round table like 45 minutes
i will say um
it's still like when you go in like
despite it being such a small like play
space
when finishing this game is like a seven
to eight hour endeavor so it is one of
those things like you you have to get
kind of get used to the repetition yeah
like obviously every loop you can you're
going to discover new things and you're
going to apply things differently but it
is that one space right it is it is so
it you know if you get bored easily or
you get frustrated easily yeah they say
looking at the same living room for
eight hours might not do it yeah yeah
yeah no jump in get repetitive yeah just
because it it's you know that's the loop
that's right a lot of testing things
like okay that didn't work that didn't
work exactly right but i think this game
works in game pass
um absolutely
i think i think it gives you
a fresh uh look at a different game that
you would not normally you know you know
play
you know yes you know sovereign would
have played this game sovereign would
have threw the money down for this game
yeah but um
maybe you know stuff like this opens up
point and clicks and bring these games
back because they did drop grim fandango
and um what was the other game that they
dropped throttle
yeah
right so
they dropping these games in there to
get your palette wet back for uh these
type of games yeah you know
the same way i feel about the skyrim um
they're re-releasing stuff like that in
there to get your palate wet for the
next one um and i think these games will
have a place to breathe right like could
you imagine like i don't i haven't
finished the story i don't you know know
anything so you guys will i will
probably just be talking to the air
right now but um could you imagine them
doing that side apartment or whatever
that i couldn't get into or you know
something else on another floor right
and stuff like that and just adding to
that game right um i know where you're
going
yeah
this game can live and grow
into different things if if it's
well-respected that's what i was about
to say yeah i'll be honest with you
that's hot that's that's a hot way to
think about it yeah i think look it it i
didn't know what to expect right so it
is super addicting like i'm like oh i'm
going to pay for 12 10 10 12 minutes and
i'm going to bed just so i can say i
played it and give some brief impression
or whatever and then it was like four
hours later and i'm still in here trying
to see what's going on and i'm moving
things around the house and sleeping
pills and whatever but anyway um yeah
it's a unique premise i think it's
really cool i think to king's point the
dev has a lane in this this could be a
lane for this type of a genre kind of
thing
i will say it is not for everyone though
because like i said if
if you don't like repeating things and
then replaying and getting a little bit
of more information here on certain
things and it's almost like a timed
narrative roguelike
i thought it was dope that the character
is aware when it happens and talks
himself through now like tessar's point
there's some times where
the reactions of what you do is spot on
with the voice acting like yo i wasn't
supposed to do that yeah that makes
sense she saw me do x y and z and i
wasn't supposed to do that you know what
i'm saying in her face right cool then
there's other times when i'm like i just
did something outlandish and you had a
very
some some characters have very relaxed
reaction there's certain things you know
so i was like okay cool my main look i
like the game i like the guy i think
they got i got to my main issue though
is what kids said
the control
bro like like i was like yeah it's not a
lot going on here
so why am i doing the point click to
move around
there's a lot of things that are time
sensitive and you got to be like yo i
gotta hurry up
because i know what's about to happen if
i and if you're not if you're fighting
with the control
to get that done it it it upsets you it
takes a little bit out of the experience
because there's certain things you gotta
do because the game will give you audio
clues as far as where's the time of
where this thing is about to happen this
major event or so on and so forth and
and the last point i'll say is i just
think that look the game is fun
i still enjoy it
i do feel so
the devs try to force a specific
style or path
that
for the most part i agree that makes
sense but there's like one or two i'm
like
i don't know about this particular
decision that you wanting me to do in
order for me to advance and keep going
right so for the most part i would say
from my experience i didn't finish it
but i got i got a lot of hours in it but
i would say there was probably out of
set like there was 25 percent of the
actions and i'm like
i don't know about that part right there
yeah but other than that nah i thought
it flowed good i thought i think the
things yeah you're 100 right i think
this game like king said couldn't evolve
because i think it does things in in the
point-and-click genre in the adventure
game genre that again old games just
didn't do well right yeah um and that
specific thing where it's like okay
give me more options within
within the the general sort of guideline
of what i have to do yeah in order to
reach if you let's say you still want me
to reach the same ending right whatever
the case may be it's not a choose your
own adventure type thing but if you give
me different options on how to get there
and there is that a little bit of that
wiggle room and that flexibility yes
um and that flexibility comes from the
fact that another thing that they do
better than classic adventure games is
that the puzzles aren't as obtuse as old
yeah true truth
everything like if you think about the
things that you the things in the
environment that you can manipulate and
what their uses would be
it you know the flow from a to b is very
it's linear you can understand it right
oh they were old at um adventure games
yeah you have something you like what
the hell do i use this for right and
when you finally figure out what you're
using for you're looking at like nah no
way
yeah there's no way this is this isn't
that so it does a lot of things right um
in order to sort of bring that genre
back to the forefront but there are
still things that i think yeah they can
really do if you give me if you give me
like a choose your own adventures oh
yeah they gotta like
five different ways to do this oh it'd
be crazy yeah yeah that would be crazy
so i hope that that that's what they're
thinking about you know right the next
the foundation is excellent and i think
that i will say this that's what i'll
say is that there's some parts where it
gets chilling bro like it gets dark
you'll be like yo what's going on
based on certain things and yes you know
certain things i'm like yo why are you
lying but anyway
that's what i that's what i will say
there was there was parts where it's
like when certain actions happen
it's so cold-blooded yes it's so
cold-blooded and matter-of-factly that
it happens and i'm like what the hell
it's like
yo one last thing i'll say i gotta i
thought it was funny that i was this is
the beaty spot that eat that major but
it's like that point where i'm trying to
take control of this situation right so
i was like nah i ain't doing none of
this i'm calling 5-0 yo they out here
they're doing this there's like yeah but
we're not going to be here until 15
minutes
i was like oh man
that part i go for i laugh because i was
like i'm not doing all this i'm going to
report a such and such it's going down
and i'm calling i'm snitching is is this
one or is that
gay was like now that's the funny thing
and that's the funny thing right as soon
as i got my hands on the phone i'm like
all right there's nothing that i've seen
to this point that gives me a phone
number to call yes i'm just gonna down
9-1-1
the fact that i called 9-1-1 manually
and it worked yeah i thought it was
awesome i thought that's kind of dope
but look listen y'all got to play it's a
unique experience i i think the devs do
have is great it's not going to be for
everyone but
i think people who love this type of
genre i mean are really gonna enjoy
themselves i to three pitch points i
haven't got to the ending i heard the
ending is very polarizing so i don't
know what's gonna go there how i
ultimately feel but it's worth the price
of admission like king said perfect game
pass game you should check it out they
they deserve that i feel that that and
to be fair there is multiple endings yes
you can go back and that kind of ups the
replay yeah there is there's an ending
that you can get right at the start of
the game basically as well yes yes yes
so that's all i got everybody we got a
lot of stupid any more super chats then
we get about here we oh yeah hold on we
have a few three we have a few
uh we have
a con artistic 10 super chat i'm chiming
in late but halo infinite shouldn't be
delayed my guess single player doesn't
make sense to play co-op story line with
multiple master cheese thank you maybe
co-op will be added
chief this is
quick question since we're talking about
indies did lord [ __ ] ever beat i know he
played the pathless
the gunk is reconfirmed for 2021 and is
also confirmed for gamescom one of my
most anticipated games of the year
image inform has has not missed this one
yeah uh the gun
anything those guys do um steam what is
the steam world oh yeah it's it's crazy
raid and blade five possibly chat i'm
playing art of rally ascent downloaded
diablo 2 and i have to finish one of
three to play 12 minutes
back long rail exactly backlog problems
yep all right cool and then for me i
just want to shout out in the realm we
did get some sweat shout out to noob
cybot yo jp 45 you got that classic t i
see you with the drip i see you salute
you know what i'm saying so we got to
salute y'all but look we got a shout out
yes i'm sorry anything else real quick
flame yeah five dollars we chat uh we
won't be there until 15 minutes okay
honey help me move the couch
but that's all we got we gotta salute
lord three make his move pull it up with
the characters
dave view i wanted to do more official
but uh our schedule's been so crazy but
i had to get you in you know what i'm
saying but where can the five people
find you what you got going on sir
yeah appreciate the invite i always love
talking halo delay
let's go love it
you guys can find me on twitter at the
vghd my youtube channel is the
videogameshd and i'll be seeing you guys
on the next show oh wait i'm on a couple
of different shows yes right are you on
xbox ultimate
every friday with we call the
magnificent seven whoa over there
and then i'm on xbox factor with mr
boomstick
to the magnificent series
i appreciate that the knowledge you
always drop in and like i said we will
be
having you on more in the future so
don't you worry about it but and of
course the o.g the legend
questionable profile pick i thought we
would pass that but i'm gonna let it
slide he was doing so
you know what i love about kit like he's
so funny and it's just like
i've i'm trying to be with you i i can't
click like on this
because i never told you this kid like
there's times you'll put something like
damn it's so funny i want to click like
but i got to be mature i got to stay out
of the kid likes this more i got to stay
out but kid what's going on we're going
to pop you and find you there
and dad you can follow me on twitter at
kiss move youtube um at kidsmove and i'm
just
i'm just having fun honestly that that
picture i did not think i thought it was
you know image that people would just
blow by i did not think it was gonna do
that honestly it was not my idea
um but i appreciate you guys man like i
said i always try to catch you guys on
sundays um uh every week i'm happy i got
sundays all off so i'm always i've been
able to catch the show almost every week
now so salute um and that's been good
but shout out to you to catch us
[Music]
i know i'm sure you're aware of this but
people are having a lot of fun with that
profile pic
there's a lot of uh edits
those are good forget continue what else
you got going on man yeah playing xbox
what's going on oh yeah xbox of course
every wednesday ltg lg ltd let's talk
games with surgery great um
we do that um like we try to we try to
aim for every friday or saturday but you
know i have been busy but um other than
that i mean yeah you obviously know me
i'm on weapon will podcast every um
sundays
but um but yeah man nothing much going
on just waiting for these games what we
got next cycle nuts too so yeah that's
two games next week
wow
seven percent of people play halo
campaign co-op fake news all right man
we got you shout out to those seven
percent
for the three months
had to bounce out but lord solving to
find people find you what you got going
on yeah first up big shout out to three
bit and it's it's kids moving of course
tony polanco always fun to have man it's
been a long time coming for sure man but
thank you guys for coming through uh you
guys could catch me lordsab iop uh on
twitter bx7 psn xbox live i will i'll be
actually be playing some ghosts of sushi
fight my issues with the game
yes
we haven't planned a date for that yet
but yes that's going down we got the
members crazy dude that's going to be so
i don't even want to talk i'm going to
be out of control
speculation she got his m7 magnificent
seven repping i see you you know what
i'm saying lord king rapping doing the
marathon great man talk today so i'm
sorry i got emotional because you know i
got to defend you i get it i get a
little emotional sometimes
and
i understood man but it's different
things i had to look into the lines and
see the hurt where it came from and you
know
um
hopefully with this if
look at what i said to know that i
wasn't calling him that but
you know it's it's easy to be taken left
we don't know when we say words
we don't know how they received it's
just you know we say them so it was
carelessly said so how it received uh
should have been talked about but anyway
um
three bit yo
magnificent seven love that name
and you came in he was trying to be
logical and i just just kept on pushing
you off and pivot yeah
to smoke with you yeah yeah
leaky jake i was like
[Laughter]
come
when i saw it i was like oh dude press
it
take that over there oh because it's
going to perpetuate a fake thought
pattern that that's not you i already
know it's not you you because you play
on everything so it really doesn't
matter you know everybody want to
categorize you as one thing but you're
not you know you're just a gamer and
you're just passionate about stuff that
you love so and i love that about you
remember we talked about that whole part
and i was just like double down on you
because you are absolutely probably the
most funniest dude no he's hilarious
i've ever he's absolutely hilarious
after watching you take that hot chip
challenge and i knew i was up next for
it boy you put the scare god in me
i'm not even gonna lie
i didn't know he was in a wheelchair
um
i didn't know any of that stuff
uh because whenever i did read his
articles or whatever
that's that's how we view gamers we
don't ever view any disabilities we just
view our brother
right and that's all i saw today was a
brother that shares the same passion
that i share and it's in a situation
that i'm in and um just to see
a dominican
you understand like i'm sorry guys
it puts a different spin on the whole
thing because this party is open for all
facts right you know you mexican you're
cuban you're whatever man you love
saying different too yeah
but everybody so like get in here you
know mix it around talk to people rub
elbows ask questions you need help do
that thing don't ever be afraid to dm
somebody or to text somebody and ask
them your or respectfully y'all i love
your stuff um
how can i you know do because i always
send them to addict
because i don't know any technical stuff
y'all think i do i don't i don't like
your addict knows that but um it's just
listen guys it's it's available for
everybody and there's no there's some
people that's trying to get keeper but i
think those barriers are being broken
down yeah um you can catch me on fridays
at legion of doom
formerly dcx open mic where you can
catch wild out statues like my boy maul
back there
um
that statue i waited for it and uh god
gave me a second chance at getting it
because it's really sold out it's crazy
um the kos is going up you're gonna see
the lizard up there he's gonna move for
me he's going back inside with
and um
i didn't want to put it out because we
just did uh the round table yeah yeah
for the patrons that members yep
urge yeah that was a dope show yeah
it's it's a deeper
dive into us individuals it's like get
to know the lords you know what i'm
saying it's kind of crazy because i
didn't think it was ever going to go to
that space and there's some spaces in
there that it's really it's some real
deep stuff there guys and go check it
out because i think more content is like
that is needed because the question
was a thought-provoking question by one
of our esteemed patreon members that had
the courage to ask a question that he
was struggling with and i had to answer
his question with all honesty from my
heart very real questions with ass you
know yes yeah
amazing no doubt no doubt real quick i
think um hustle and motivate want to
know the website that you get the
statutes from what you want to talk
about xm
oh um okay so
this uh xm studios is xmstudios.com
uh sideshow
is the ones where you see
uh like the greater
a variety
if you're a new collector i'm going to
always send you straight to sideshow um
because they have uh competitive prices
they in the us when they're shipping uh
xm studios is outside the us so unless
you want to pay 500 a shipper statue
um so you know
god knows you know 60 70 bucks um to
ship a statue he was like yo he's
raising the eyebrow i'm like that's just
nothing bro but they have a variety for
you there and they have different things
so you can go there and you can get
different you can get things for wifey a
lot of us tend to forget
either our girlfriends or our wives uh
are gamers because or they they share
some form of passion comic book lovers
or or art uh uh uh
yeah there's a whole bunch of stuff at
sideshow.com you can go there don't be
scared to share your passion with your
loved one because sometimes when you got
your passion
she feels excluded
includer
so that way you ain't gonna hide it when
you buy
no salute no doubt you're you know
delilah greece thank you king yes
what's up leave it
okay i was just saying good advice yeah
that was good it's actually good advice
i've been down uh 20 years 10 years deep
so uh yeah so listen to what i said
i already see uk big up i said oh
effects
yeah big up big up any super chats if we
get out of here man uh raiden blade two
pound super chat oh my god psychonauts 2
also helped my eyes
here we got right in blade again
guyanese oh guyana you're done though
oh you got the routine all right see
what's going on yes
we got best-selling finest 2000
sovereign i just hit you up on twitter
yes sir i just followed you i did i
didn't know i didn't know you had a
twitter
couldn't find it it's all good man look
yo tremendous show tony polanco killed
it today absolute pleasure salute to
paris for pulling up you know what i'm
saying three bit a pleasure brother
always like your inside kiss move the
best spot you already know what it is
salute that's family he said addict some
love but look we're back we got more fun
stuff planned cannot wait super excited
everybody enjoy your sunday and in a few
more weeks we'll be moving to 11 a.m
you know that no kidding's not happening
please any any announcements about stuff
coming this week or you are not doing
that yet oh not yet right yeah yeah
without yeah
things things are coming things because
a lot of fun stuff but that's all i got
we out
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you